So.
Da bin ich.
Heute zweimal 10 Kilometer.
Nee, nee, nee.
Ziemlich genau 10.
10,2 oder 10,12.
Oder sowas.
So, dann wollen wir mal gucken,
wie schnell ich heute gewesen bin.
Ich war auf jeden Fall heute nicht
rekordverdächtig schnell.
Wenn ich jetzt noch finden würde, wo ich meine App habe.
Hier.
Wollen wir doch mal gucken.
Nein, nicht Indoor-Cycling.
Are now running.
Durchschnittliche Herzfrequenz
158.
Pace 6 Minuten 30
pro Kilometer. Also heute war ich echt nicht
rekordverdächtig schnell.
10,12 Kilometer.
Und
was sagt der Performance-Graph?
Also
verbraucht habe ich 879
Kalorien. Das genieße ich
ja immer mit so einer Portion Skepsis, ob das
so stimmt. Aber ich denke mal so
Plus, Minus, so grob
wird das hinkommen.
10,12 Kilometer. Eine Stunde
5. 50
heißt
im Durchschnitt 1,3
Kilometer pro Stunde.
9,3 Kilometer
pro Stunde.
Und
wo ist der Graph, den ich mir immer
angucke?
Durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit 6,30.
Beste Geschwindigkeit 4,30.
Herzfrequenz im Durchschnitt 158.
Maximum 184.
Ja, da bin ich mal kurz geflitzt
zwischendurch. Maximaler
Trainingseffekt 5,0. Mehr geht nicht.
Hast du schon
ein neues Bike bestellt? Ne.
5,0. Also mehr Trainingseffekt kann man
in dieser App nicht haben.
In der Garmin App.
5,0
Aerobic Trainingseffekt
und 2,5 an Aerobic
Trainingseffekt
Ja, 20 Höhenmeter
ist jetzt nicht viel
insgesamt. So, Performance
Condition. Die erste Hälfte
Plus 2. Die zweite
Hälfte Minus 1. Okay.
War ich ein bisschen zu lab.
Aber die zweite Hälfte checkt das immer nicht so richtig.
Weil da geht es konstant ein bisschen
den Berg auf. Erst erste Brücke,
dann zweite Brücke, dann dritte Brücke
und da bin ich immer
langsamer und da denkt das Ding, ja, das liegt nicht
an den Brücken, sondern das muss eindeutig daran
liegen, dass du es sagst.
Obviously. So.
Der Rest sieht gut aus.
Alles klar.
So.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab immer so einen Puls von 158,
160 rum.
So in dem Dreh, da geht das gut. Da kann ich
am Stück ohne Probleme
längere Zeit rennen.
Und, also maximalen Puls
hab ich
also irgendwas um
keine Ahnung, 194 oder sowas.
Das ist relativ
viel für mein Alter, aber es ist ja je nach Person
unterschiedlich.
So.
Jetzt bin ich aber im Arsch, Alter.
Jetzt muss ich auch
erstmal ein bisschen warten, bis sich das alles wieder beruhigt hat.
Und was gibt's besseres, Leute?
Als zur Beruhigung
Arch Linux Package Updates zu machen.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, wir haben zwar
gestern Abend erst Arch Linux Package Updates
gemacht, aber
das ist Arch Linux.
Yep, Clock, es wird Zeit.
Gibt garantiert wieder neue
Updates. Jetzt mal checken.
Pac-Man.
Und?
Siehste?
Guck mal, sogar ein neuer Linux-Kernel
gibt es.
G-Streamer wird geupdatet.
Und ein neuer Linux-Kernel
ja dann. Let's go.
6.6.10.
Soll ich nachgucken, was es da Neues gab?
Ne, ist mir egal.
Funktioniert in der Regel ja ohne Probleme.
So, gucken, ob's
Arch User Linux
Arch User
Repo Updates gibt.
Ja, Notizprogramm, was ich eigentlich
hier gar nicht bräuchte, weil ich hier in der
VM nix, warum ist die Musik so laut
auf einmal?
Anzeige.
Jetzt ist es wieder leiser.
Playlist. Okay, Reboot.
Haben geupdatet.
Pog.
Moin, ich hätte mal eine Frage bezüglich Wayland.
Oh, jetzt geht's aber los hier.
Kann es sein, dass die Maus ab und zu unsichtbar
wird? Liegt das an was
anderem als an Wayland?
Also ganz ehrlich, im Zweifelsfall liegt es an Wayland.
Also, wenn du in der
VM bist, dann macht Wayland richtig
Probleme.
Weil nicht, dass X perfekt laufen würde, aber
X funktioniert bei mir in der VM deutlich
besser als Wayland.
Also, wenn du es native installiert
auf Bare Metal, naja, im Zweifelsfall
du meinst aber nicht, dass
die Maus unsichtbar wird, wenn du im Browser
tippst, oder? Also ich meine, hier habe ich das nicht, aber es gibt
ja manche Browser, wenn du anfängst zu
tippen, oder Programme, wenn du anfängst zu tippen,
blenden die die Maus aus. Das ist
es wahrscheinlich nicht, oder? Da wärst du auch schon
selbst drauf gekommen. Im Zweifelsfall,
ganz ehrlich, geh davon
aus, dass es Wayland ist.
Rechne damit, dass es Wayland ist.
Und dass sich das wahrscheinlich von selbst mit der
Zeit fixt.
Wobei das ja auch so eine Never-Ending-Story
ist mit Wayland.
So.
Pepo trinkt Kaffee, das soll ich auch mal machen,
aber ich trinke ja keinen Kaffee.
Wahrscheinlich der Einzige, der in der IT arbeitet, der keinen Kaffee
trinkt. Chat, haben wir
noch Tee-Enjoyers hier?
Die auch lieber Tee anstatt
Kaffee trinken. Ich meine, ich kann Kaffee trinken,
ist nicht so, als müsste ich davon jetzt irgendwie kotzen,
oder so. Aber ich mag
das nicht sonderlich. Ich trinke lieber Tee.
Dann auf dem Teambuilding-Workshop, da hatten
die auch so eine große
so eine Wand mit verschiedenen Tee-Sorten
drin. Da habe ich auch den ganzen Tag
über Tee getrunken. Und tatsächlich
auch ordentlich Zucker reingeklatscht,
damit ich wach bleibe.
Bisschen, muss ein bisschen
äh... Okay, wir haben auch
Tee-Enjoyers. Exzellent.
So.
Package geupdatet.
Da habe ich mal eine Weile
so Ingwer-Tee getrunken.
Da muss ich sagen, den mag ich mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Ändert sich mit der Zeit.
Moin. So, wo wir gerade
dabei sind. Was geht dann so auf
Shithub ab? Was trendet
weekly auf Github?
AI?
Überspringen wir.
Movie Web.
Aha.
Irgendein
Plesk oder sowas.
Ich habe legit keine Ahnung,
was es ist.
Movie Web.App
Moment.
Wait a minute. Ist das...
Ist das, ähm...
MonkaTOS?
Ist das MonkaTOS, das Ding?
Okay, wir können...
Wir können einfach mal testen, ob das MonkaTOS ist.
Wir gucken jetzt nix.
John Wick.
Okay, es ist definitiv MonkaTOS,
Alter.
Da mache ich garantiert im Stream nix an, ey.
Das...
Das gibt es garantiert nicht kostenlos zu
watchen, ey.
Ups.
SpotTube.
Ja. Das ist ein
Spotify-Client
mit eingebautem Werbeblocker.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es dazu...
Ob es dazu...
Also, ob man es dazu benutzen kann,
quasi Spotify ohne Abo
alles sich anzugucken, ohne von Werbung
geneift zu werden. Müssten wir mal ausprobieren.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich zumindest...
Nicht Monka-Urheberrecht-TOS,
aber das ist höchstwahrscheinlich
Monka-Spotify-TOS, das Ding.
Letztendlich ist es aber auch egal,
weil es nicht TOS gegen den Softwareentwickler ist,
weil der Softwareentwickler da nicht dagegen verstößt,
sondern die Leute, die es
einsetzen
und dementsprechend...
Ja.
Kann der Spotify eh nix machen.
Die haben bestimmt
Safe-Lizenzen gekauft. Bestimmt.
Geh ich auch stark von aus. Die haben alles lizenziert.
Mit Sicherheit.
Safe-Call.
Okay.
Umi OCR.
Klingt irgendwie nach Weep-Texterkennungssoftware.
Ja.
Auf jeden Fall.
Die Sache ist bloß immer...
Das ist Japanisch, oder?
Übersetzen in Englisch.
Chine?
Ne.
Bestimmt Japanisch, oder? Chat-Gil.
Open Source. Batch-Ready. Offline-OCR-Software.
Okay.
Ah, ja, ja.
Texterkennung.
In QML. Okay, das ist eine Qt-Anwendung.
Das passt natürlich auch.
Wo ist der Quellcode hier?
Äh, Qt-Python-Stelz.
Sieht man auch selten.
Okay.
Ähm, Lebenslauf-Webseite.
Android-Hackermans.
Was ist denn?
Was ist denn das schon wieder?
Lass mich raten.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was es ist, aber...
Die Rust-Community löst wieder Probleme in Rust, die es nicht gibt.
Ich vermute, dass es wieder so ein Projekt ist.
Die Rust-Community löst Probleme, die es nicht gibt.
Ähm, und was ist das?
Ne, es ist ein Package-Manager.
Moment, es ist ein Package-Manager?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Ein...
Ein Virtual-Enviro-Manager?
Ein Package-Manager?
Environment-Variablen-Manager?
Und ein Task-Runner in einem?
Okay.
Ja.
Die Rust-Community löst wieder Probleme, die es nicht gibt.
Das ist ein typisches Rust-Projekt.
Ja, dann schau mal.
Ja, okay.
Ey, ich...
Ach, man kann doch nicht mal Pause machen.
Das ist ja sehr...
Kann man das nicht?
Ey, was ist das denn?
Ah, nee.
What the...
Man kann nicht Pause drücken.
Ja.
HTTP ist...
Nein.
Bestimmt auch ein Rust-Curl oder so.
Ja.
Okay, es ist...
Es ist ein...
Node-Package-Manager,
ein Node-Version-Manager,
beziehungsweise Virtual-Environment-Manager
und ein Task-Runner in einem.
Ja.
Okay, die Rust-Community löst Probleme, die es nicht gibt.
Dann haben wir Kubernetes-GPT.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Das Projekt habe ich schon vor einer Weile gesehen.
Falls es das ist, was ich meine.
Wo ich auch nicht verstanden habe, warum das Leute verwenden.
Das ist...
Das ist doch...
Ach, nee, Moment.
Nee, das ist ein anderes Projekt.
Das ist ein anderes Projekt.
Das habe ich jetzt verwechselt.
Das ist ein Kubernetes-Cluster-Scanner,
der versucht mittels AI oder sowas
zu erkennen, ob man Security-Probleme im Cluster hat.
Ist nicht eigentlich so ein grundsätzliches Security-Problem,
dass ich meine gesamte Kubernetes-Cluster-Konfiguration
dazu eventuell in die Cloud schicke.
Ist das nicht eigentlich deutlich Security-relevanter
als das, was das Ding findet?
So mal, ketzerische Frage.
Ob sich da noch Secrets oder so dabei sind?
Egal.
AI.
Merch-Kit.
Tools for Merching.
Preach.
Okay.
AI.
Maui.
Wisst ihr, ich warte eigentlich jeden Tag darauf,
dass Microsoft ankündigt, dass Maui eingestellt wird.
Würde es irgendjemand legit überraschen,
wenn Maui eingestellt wird?
Würde euch das überraschen?
Ich meine, wir kennen Microsofts Geschichte mit UI-Frameworks.
Also ich warte jeden Tag darauf, dass ein Blogpost kommt,
Maui wird eingestellt.
Weil benutzen tut das eh keiner, der bei Verstand ist.
Sogar der ursprüngliche Gründer von Xamarin
ist ja auch weg von Microsoft jetzt.
Eines seiner Kritikpunkte war ja,
Microsoft weiß nicht, was sie damit treiben.
Und so sehr ich .NET, C-Sharp und das Ökosystem
da drumherum mag, Maui ist Shit.
Genauso wenig mag ich, aber das hat viele Anhänger,
verstehe ich zwar nicht, aber okay.
Genauso wenig mag ich Blazor.
Blazor ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich habe das am Anfang mal ausprobiert.
So nice das klingt, C-Sharp im Browser hat mich das nicht überzeugt.
Ich sollte es vielleicht mal wieder ausprobieren,
weil ich meine, vielleicht hat sich ja die letzten zwei,
drei Jahre da was geändert.
Aber Blazor und Maui sind so Dinger, die werden super gehypt von Microsoft.
Und selbst ich als .NET Fanboy muss sagen,
so wirklich toll finde ich es nicht.
Okay, Bitcoin in C++.
Darktable.
Oh, das gibt es auch noch.
JavaScript.
ESP Async Web Server.
Krass, das trendet?
Das gibt es schon ewig.
Ja, warum?
Letztes Komet 2022.
Warum trendet es denn jetzt?
Das ist so random, einfach.
Es gibt Sachen, die muss man nicht verstehen.
Ja, Darktables ist sehr beliebt.
Das habe ich auch schon.
Nee, nee, nee, wie heißt es?
Doch, Darktable.
Ja, das habe ich schon öfters gehört, dass es sehr pock sein muss.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Irgendwas auf Spanisch oder Portugiesisch.
Chat, wer kennt sich aus Spanisch oder Portugiesisch?
Ich tippe fast schon ein bisschen.
Richtung Portugiesisch.
Vielleicht ist es auch Italienisch, aber ich glaube, es ist Portugiesisch.
Kann man erkennen lassen, was das ist?
Ich glaube, Google kann Sprachen.
Google Translate.
Ist nicht Russisch.
Spanisch, okay, nein, das ist Spanisch.
Es ist, okay, um was geht es da?
Weekly Programming Challenges 2024.
Ah, so quasi Advent of Code.
In Spanisch, guck mal, der streamt sogar die Sachen auf Twitch.
Es ist ein bisschen sowas wie Advent of Code, nur das ist nicht Advent of Code, sondern 2024 of Code ist auf Spanisch und es sind anscheinend auch eher Einsteigerkurs mäßig was interessant.
Ja, da ist er, nice.
Ich finde es gut, dass es immer mehr Content gibt in der Richtung für Native Speaker.
Also es hat sich ja die letzten Jahre auch in Deutschland so ein bisschen etabliert, dass es deutlich mehr Technik-Channels gibt.
Sei es jetzt, die sich mit Softwareentwicklung oder Linux oder sonst was beschäftigen.
Das wird in anderen Ländern auch so sein.
Natürlich, international, rein englischsprachig hast du immer noch die größte Breite, die du ansprechen kannst.
Aber gerade auf YouTube finde ich das gut.
Weil das ist was anderes, ob du jemandem zuhörst, der deine Native Sprache spricht oder Englisch.
Man kann sich ohne Probleme, 99% der Sachen höre ich.
Ich höre es mir auch auf Englisch an, aber ich finde es nicht schlecht, wenn es auch Native Speaker Content immer gibt.
Solange die nicht unbedingt ihre Variablen auf Deutsch benennen, dann ist alles gut.
Was sind deine Favoriten auf Deutsch?
Da müsste ich mir Gedanken machen.
Also wenn ich mir tatsächlich gerne angucke, ist Algorithmen verstehen.
Der Florian, der nicht mal Algorithmen verstehen heißt.
Denke ich mir gerne an, ab und zu.
Das ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, jedes.
Das Video ist vom Thema, was mich brennend interessiert.
Aber kannst du ja auch nicht haben.
Im englischsprachigen Bereich gucke ich mir, was C Sharp angeht, gerne Nick Chapsas an.
Wobei wir sind bei deutschsprachigen Sachen.
Da müsste ich mir Gedanken drüber machen.
Fällt mir jetzt spontan aus dem Florian nicht so viel ein.
Morpheus gucke ich auch ab und zu, ja.
Ja, ja.
Echt?
Ich muss immer noch sagen, wenn ich das jetzt noch richtig schreiben könnte.
Ah, hier, genau.
Ich war...
Okay.
Dann habe ich es kaputt.
Müssten VPN-Anbieter mitloggen?
Naja.
Au.
Okay, ne, dafür muss ich mir nicht angucken.
Aber es ist so.
Meiner Einschätzung nach und ich gehe mal auch davon aus, dass das das ist, was im Video gesagt wird.
VPN-Anbieter müssen prinzipiell das machen, was in den Gesetzen steht.
Nachdem das das...
Nachdem das ja für Deutschland vorgeschrieben ist.
Aber VPN-Anbieter.
... auf irgendeinem Inselstaat in sonst wo ansässig sind, dann kann Ihnen da im Endeffekt keiner einen Strick draus drehen, wenn Sie das nicht machen.
Und dementsprechend, eventuell müssten Sie das gesetzlich, praktisch gesehen, passiert auch nichts, wenn Sie es nicht machen.
Zumal Sie ja auch offensiv damit werben, es nicht zu machen.
Inwieweit das stimmt, wo wir da beim eigentlichen Problem bei der ganzen VPN-Anbieter-Geschichte sind, ist, musst du Ihnen trauen, dass Sie das machen.
Und ob du den VPN-Anbietern traust, ich weiß ja nicht.
Das ist garantiert ein AI-generatedes Bild.
Sieht so AI-generated aus.
Ach, guck mal, hat er so einen silbernen Playbutton, nice.
Do you remember your first subscriber?
Den kenne ich, ich kenne meinen ersten Subscriber.
Das war der Felix von...
Mein Kollege von der alten Arbeit.
Den habt ihr auch mal auf einem Gamescom-Video gehört.
Falls sich da noch einer dran erinnern kann.
Ich glaube, das war mein erster Abonnent.
Der Felix, ich kann mich echt an meinen ersten Abonnent erinnern.
Oder einer der ersten, aber ich glaube, der erste.
Alakriti trendet, ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe nicht, warum Westterm nicht jede Woche trendet.
Das ist einfach das beste Terminal, was es gibt.
Meinst du WilliPietKas?
Nein, der heißt auch Felix, aber den meine ich nicht.
Ich, warte mal, Felix?
Max, MaxFPS, Felix, Gamescom?
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Mit dem habe ich mal ein Video aufgenommen, wo wir waren zusammen auf der Gamescom.
Nee, nee, nicht WilliPietKas.
Ehemaliger Kollege von mir von der alten Arbeit.
Mit dem ich mich gut verstanden habe, mit dem ich heute immer noch ab und zu schreibe.
Obwohl wir nicht mal beim gleichen Laden arbeiten.
Das war mein erster Abonnent.
Ja, wie gesagt, anstatt Alakriti sollte Westterm trenden.
Westterm ist das beste, beste Terminal, was es gibt.
Obviously, sonst würde ich es ja nicht verwenden.
Beste.
Und ich habe es euch ja schon ein paar mal gezeigt,
dass mit Abstand beste Feature
von Westterm ist,
nicht nur Bildersupport auf der Kommandozeile, sondern
Animated GIF Support auf der Kommandozeile.
Das ist das, was die Welt gebraucht hat und was viel zu wenige Terminals können.
Ich glaube, das einzige Terminal, was es auch noch
gescheit mit zumindest was, was man Standard nennen kann,
beherrscht, ist glaube ich iTerm.
Oder iTerm 2 heißt es, glaube ich, ne?
Mac OS Enjoyers, wo seid ihr?
iTerm heißt das.
Das kann das auch noch.
Die anderen Terminals haben irgendwelche
proprietären Sachen, die dadurch wieder andere Probleme verursachen.
Ich weiß noch, es...
Ich glaube, KITI ist das andere Terminal, was das auch gut kann mit Images.
KITI, der KITI-Autor sagt, aber TMAX darf nicht verwendet werden, weil TMAX sagt.
Das Problem ist nur, man braucht TMAX.
Zwar nicht unbedingt lokal, aber über SSH auf dem Server.
Und ich kann kein Terminal benutzen als
Daily Driver, wie man so schön sagt, wo TMAX nicht richtig funktioniert.
Und Westterm kann halt alles.
Westterm kann
TMAX-Funktionen
ohne, dass man TMAX braucht.
Lokal.
Hat aber auch keine Probleme damit,
wenn man remote einen TMAX ausschürt.
Funktioniert auch ohne jegliche Probleme alles.
Und ansonsten, es ist saumäßig schnell.
Es hat Transparenz-Effekte.
Ganz wichtig natürlich, ja.
Es hat GIF- und Bild-Unterstützung.
Mit einem kleinen Skript von mir kann es sogar SVGs anzeigen.
Guck.
So, ich hab so ein kleines Skript gebastelt.
Da kann das sogar SVGs anzeigen.
Das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Muss ich mal kurz gucken, wie ich das gebaut hab.
Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Ah, hier, okay.
Skript da, Hackerman-Stells.
Was hab ich denn, was hab ich denn da gebaut?
Versteh ich, versteh ich das noch, was ich da gebaut hab?
Äh...
Zahlnahme...
Ach, hier, genau.
Hier ist das, hier ist das, wie das anzeigt.
Genau, wenn's...
Genau, wenn's ein SVG ist,
ein SVG-Vektorformat kann das Ding standardmäßig nicht anzeigen,
dann nimmt es FFmpeg,
wandelt das SVG um
in ein 640er, äh...
PNG, 46 Pixel breites wahrscheinlich PNG-Bild.
Aspect Ratio wird preserved.
PNG pipet Standard-Out raus
und ImageCat bekommt das Ganze im Standard-In.
Und zeigt das mit 20% Höhe an.
Ja.
Das ist, das ist, dass es SVGs anzeigen kann.
Und FFmpeg ist einfach so ein richtig nices...
Nein, es kann keine SVGs anzeigen.
Korrekt.
Also, das an sich nicht.
Aber das kann PNGs anzeigen.
Und wenn man vorher das SVN in PNG umwandelt, geht's.
Nee, selbst kann's keine SVGs anzeigen.
Vielleicht, vielleicht kann es das mittlerweile, ja.
Ich bin mir da gar nicht so sicher.
Mal gucken, ob's da irgendwas gibt hier.
Aber wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich sagt er, nee, gibt's nicht.
SVG-Support für Animated Background.
PDF.
Okay, nee, haben sie, haben sie anscheinend keinen Bock drauf.
Wir können mal probieren.
Nee, es kann kein, kann kein SVG.
Ja.
Aber finde ich nicht schlimm.
Ganz ehrlich, besser ist keine eine Sache gut.
Und man kann ja die Sachen, die man anzeigen möchte, selbst umwandeln.
Wichtig ist, dass es eine Schnittstelle hat, um Bilder im Terminal anzuzeigen.
Und das ist halt sehr, sehr nice, dass das funktioniert.
Dann braucht man keine extra Sperenzchen mehr, wenn man mal gucken will,
aha, welches Bild ist das?
Zack.
Sogar GIF-Support auf der Kommandozeile.
Beste.
Ist die Musik irgendwie aus?
Ja.
Ist nur 23 Minuten lang.
Für sie kurz, hä?
Okay, Chris, Christmas, Christmas-Music ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu übertrieben jetzt.
Auch mal keine Christmas-Music.
Ist vorbei.
So.
Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Stimmt, ich wollte mir die Shit-Hub-Trends immer noch angucken.
Also, was trendet sonst noch?
Orca Slicer.
Ja, 3D-Drucker.
Ich muss ja sagen, ich habe meinen 3D-Drucker, glaube ich, die letzten drei Monate nicht mehr
oder die letzten vier Monate, vielleicht sogar schon das letzte halbe Jahr eher, nicht mehr
benutzt.
Ich habe das ja hauptsächlich benutzt, um irgendwelche kleinen Gehäuse für Bastelsachen
auszudrucken.
Nachdem ich in letzter Zeit aber wenig Zeug gelötet und gebastelt habe, ist das flach
gefallen.
Ich bin aber trotzdem froh, dass ich einen 3D-Drucker habe.
Ich kann den immer mal wieder brauchen.
Und sei es nur für kleine Sachen.
Letztens war ich ein bisschen pepega im Kopf.
Bei mir im Ofen, also im Backofen, da ist neben eine Lampe drin, damit der Backofen
warm bleibt.
Und die fällt raus.
Der Backofen ist halt irgendwie gefühlt auch schon 30 Jahre alt oder so.
Da ist irgendwie sowas drumherum.
Weiß nicht, was das ist.
Irgendwas Keramikmäßiges oder so.
Ist da abgebrochen und deswegen bleibt die Lampe nicht mehr hängen und die fällt raus.
Und dementsprechend habe ich kein Licht mehr im Backofen.
So.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht.
Weißt du was?
Könntest du nicht sowas 3D drucken?
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass es wahrscheinlich keine gute Idee ist, 3D-gedruckte Teile in
Backofen zu setzen.
Also als ich anfangen wollte, sowas zu erstellen, so zu gucken, ey, kriegen wir das nicht?
Dann habe ich mir gedacht, das ist doch eine gute Idee.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, das ist doch eine gute Idee.
Aber das ist ja keine super komplexe Teil, das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen mutterförmig
und das hätte ich wahrscheinlich selbst hinbekommen irgendwie zu designen das Teil, da rein
zu drücken und dann die Lampe reinzustecken.
Das Ding ist bloß, ich bin dann drauf gekommen, okay, so 270 Grad ist wahrscheinlich dann
nicht so geil für 3D-gedruckte Teile.
Deswegen habe ich dann sein lassen.
Von der Idee her wäre das eine Top-Anwendung für 3D-Drucker gewesen.
Aber Teile im Backofen sind dann doch nicht so schlau.
Ich meine, es kommt aufs Material an.
Es gibt bestimmt 3D-gedrucktes Material, was das aushält.
Das musst du dann aber selbst wahrscheinlich auch super heiß mit deinem 3D-Drucker drucken,
was wahrscheinlich mein Drucker nicht richtig kann.
Es gibt ja eh Gott und die Welt an unterschiedlichen Materialien für einen 3D-Drucker.
Guck mal, ein Half-Life-Fan.
Auch wenn das nur das Lambda-Symbol ist, aber ich interpretiere da einfach mal rein, ein Half-Life-Fan.
Da muss halt eine CNC-Fräse her.
Gibt es ja schon bei AliExpress für wenig Geld.
Ich weiß halt erstens nicht, ob das was taugt.
Eher weniger wahrscheinlich.
Und zweitens braucht das Platz.
Und drittens brauche ich das so selten, dass sich das überhaupt nicht lohnt.
Genauso wie die Leute, die so eine Wasserfräse haben.
Wie nennt sich das denn?
Diese Waterjet-Dinger haben.
So eine Wasserstrahlfräse.
Das ist auch so ein Trend auf YouTube.
Da gibt es ja seit ein paar Jahren zig.
Dicht-Channels, ne?
Ähm, Hydraulik-Pressen-Channel.
Waterjet-Channel.
Da siehst du dann im Endeffekt Leute, die in die jeweiligen Geräte immer Sachen reinstecken, die da definitiv nicht reingehören.
Das läuft aber wunderbar, weil das irgendwie so ein bisschen...
Das ist so ein bisschen wie die ganzen Satisfying-Video-Compilations.
Ja.
Und die machen dann Hydraulik-Presse vs. Stapel-Papier.
Da ist das ganz schön rumgeflogen, das Zeug.
Ich guck mir das auch manchmal gerne an.
Das ist so richtig schöner Braindead-Content, der aber so weit interessant ist, dass man trotzdem zugucken will.
Das ist so eine ganz spezielle Art von Content irgendwie.
Ja.
Hydraulik-Presse vs.
Und da gibt es ja auch noch immer Compilations.
Die Top 20 unerwartetsten Ergebnisse bei Hydraulik-Presse.
Ja, was ich meinte, sind diese Wasserstrahl-Schneidegeräte.
Da gibt es auch jede Menge.
Da gibt es auch jede Menge Channels von...
Auf YouTube.
Wenn du auf YouTube gehst, suchst du...
Waterjet.
Das ist nicht der einzige.
Was zum...
Der Finger abgeschnitten.
Aus nem...
Aus ner Hand, die aus...
Was ist das? Hähnchen oder so ist?
Ja.
Oder Hydraulik-Presse-Channel.
Da gibt es auch jede Menge von.
Guck mal.
8,87 Millionen Aufrufe.
Es gibt Hydraulik-Presse-Channel.
Crazy Hydraulik-Presse.
Guck mal hier.
Die Kokomotorzint am Start.
Ist VK nicht dieses...
Das ist nicht das russische...
Russische Social-Ding?
VK.
Server.
300 Fans Home-Server.
Okay.
Tockt das?
Hä?
An die Szene aus Mr. Robot kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Der eine erzählt nämlich, benutzt Gnome.
Und er erzählt, er benutzt KDE.
Oder so war das, glaube ich.
War das nicht so, dass Elliot erzählt, er benutzt Gnome?
Und ich hab vergessen, wie der andere Dude heißt.
Der andere Dude erzählt, er benutzt KDE?
Ja.
Da kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Mr. Robot Season 1 war richtig nice.
Die erste Hälfte Mr. Robot Season 1 war mega nice.
Danach hat es mir nicht mehr gefallen.
Auch wenn ich...
Alter, was ist mit den Shorts wieder los, Mann?
Bigger Boobs.
If you love, you restart.
Man of Culture haben sich wieder assembled hier bei den Shorts.
Boober.
Richtig, genau.
Deswegen hatte ich da auch keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Ich fand die erste...
Sagen wir mal so 80%.
80% der ersten Mr. Robot Staffel fand ich mega nice.
Der aus...
Quasi...
Wie sagt man so?
Das Finale.
Die letzten zwei Folgen von Season 1 waren schon weird champ.
Und nicht so...
Sonderlich spannend.
Und danach hatte ich gar keinen Bock mehr.
Ich hab...
Ich hab Season 2 und 3, glaube ich, gibt's noch.
Mr. Robot.
Gar nicht mehr geguckt.
Obwohl der Chat mir schon mehrfach gesagt hat, wird sich voll lohnen.
Aber hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
What the fuck?
Okay, was ist an diesem Fanless-Mini-PC so geil?
Ich sehe da schon mal...
Übrigens, richtig guter Channel.
Richtig guter Channel.
Die Webseite von denen verfolge ich seit Jahren schon.
Und gucke da auch ab und zu rein.
Also, wenn man sich für so...
So, so, so...
So Heim...
Homelab-Sachen interessiert.
Sei es jetzt für Switche oder für Mini-PCs.
Das ist ein richtig guter Channel.
Okay, was sehe ich hier?
Ich sehe hier erst einmal...
Viel Schrift drüber.
Aha, hier.
Also...
Ich sehe hier erst einmal...
Wir bekommen vier SFP-Plus-Ports.
Was für einen Mini-PC mega ist.
Normalerweise haben das höchstens etwas teurere Switche.
Vier Ports SFP-Plus.
Oder richtig teure Server.
Haben dann aber meistens sogar auch...
Auch nur Dual-Port.
10 Gig.
Dann hast du wahrscheinlich 4x1.
Das hier dürfte eventuell...
Eventuell ist das ein Management...
Ne, das ist ein Management-Interface.
So richtig Enterprise, das Ding hier.
So eine Art Management-Interface.
Externes Netzteil.
Zweimal USB.
Soll man hier eine WLAN-Antenne durchmachen?
Oder was soll uns das hier sagen?
Was soll uns dieses WLAN-Symbol hier sagen?
Sollen da WLAN-Antennen dran?
Oder?
Das ist das Loch für das Internet.
Die Kiste interessiert mich tatsächlich.
Was für das...
Moment, was ist das?
Das ist ein Atom C3758.
Ah, obviously Intel-Stells.
Ich glaube, das ist ein nicht ganz so alter Intel Atom.
C3758, gell?
Der ist alt, aber glaube ich nicht so alt.
Intel-Webseite.
Hallo?
Ah, okay.
Schon ein wenig sechs Jahre alt.
Schon etwas in die Jahre gekommene CPU.
Ich hätte sogar gedacht, dass der noch ein Ticken neuer ist.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal neu genug,
dass der Stromverbrauch nicht durch die Decke ist bei dem Ding.
Gar nicht so übel.
Haben wir da auch einen Link zu?
Ja, die Webseite ist echt gut dafür.
Cool, Tom.
Das ist irgendein China-Ding, oder?
Lass mal deinen Hersteller googeln.
KOTOM-Mini-PC.
Ist das China-Chinesen-Kram?
KOTOM.net
Hotline.
Was ist das für eine Vorwahl-Chat, gell?
Länder-Vorwahl.
Alles klar.
In Ermangelung eines China-Chinesen-Emotes
müssen die Kokomotos herhalten.
Okay, ja.
Und das ist...
Jepp-Kuck-Inseln.
Die haben 6, 8, 2.
Ja.
Okay, China-Ding.
Aber die Ausstattung...
Also, wenn das Ding wirklich nur 300 Dollar kostet...
Gucken wir mal, ob das denn auch echt der Fall ist.
Amazon.com.
Nee, da kostet schon mal...
Gut, je nachdem, was man sich für eine...
32 Giga-RAM brauchst du ja auch gar nicht.
Und ehrlich gesagt, No-RAM-SSD ist wahrscheinlich noch am besten.
Am liebsten wäre mir...
RAM ohne SSD.
Na, HDD braucht ja wirklich keiner.
Naja.
Ist das Skype?
Weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich hab jetzt...
Wie heißen die?
Q?
Wo meinst du, was ist Skype?
Das da.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Skype.
Skype in 2024.
Naja, gut.
Ich kann's ja verstehen.
Die würden...
Die verwenden bei sich nur WeChat.
Allerdings international verwendet niemand WeChat.
Okay, was kostet das Ding bei AliExpress?
Bei AliExpress ist es deutlich attraktiver vom Preis her.
Ja.
Das ist was, wo es sich tatsächlich mal lohnt,
bei AliExpress wieder mal zu bestellen.
Voraussichtliche Lieferung 29. Januar.
Was kostet die fetteste Variante?
Ja.
Unsinnig, brauchen wir nicht.
Also ich würde sagen 16...
16, 16 Gig.
Wobei, ehrlich gesagt...
Ja.
Weil wir haben ja auch...
Wer weiß, was das für eine China-Chinesen-SSD ist.
Ich glaube, am besten ist in dem Fall wirklich No-RAM, No-SSD.
Und selbst eine Samsung-SSD reingemacht und RAM.
Ich meine, das ist DDR4-RAM.
Da hat man wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein bisschen was da.
Ist das Low-Profile-RAM?
Äh...
AliExpress?
Ja.
Ja, das ist Low-Profile-RAM.
Da hab ich so...
Ich hab sogar noch DDR4-Low-Profile-RAM.
Aber ich glaub nur 4 Gig hier.
Also, mit dem RAM hab ich keine Schmerzen.
Aber ich trau da China.
SSD nicht.
Was kostet das Teuerste?
Du meinst hier unten?
Die Produktbezeichnung verwirren mich wieder.
2, 3, 3, 2, G9?
Der da.
Da, da.
Guck mal!
Da ist bei AliExpress sogar ja noch teurer.
Lul.
Ja.
Gut.
Zumindest...
Zumindest ist die Ausstattung echt gar nicht so übel.
Du bekommst im Endeffekt...
4 10-Gigabit-Ports.
Der Rest sind 2,5-Gig-Ports.
Internal Storage, mehrere SSD.
Das ist echt nicht schlecht für den Preis.
Muss man sagen.
Also, die China-Chinesen...
Wahrscheinlich ist das Ding aus irgendwelchen...
Ollen...
Also, das machen die Chinesen ja gerne.
Die kaufen alte Hardware und löten dann die CPUs ab und solche Dinger.
Und bauen daraus eigene Boards.
Letztens gab's doch...
Habt ihr das mitbekommen mit den Grafikkarten?
Wo von...
GTX...
4...
Also...
Ähm...
4900.
Oder?
Ne, Moment.
Was ist...
Was ist die aktuell schnellste Grafikkarte?
4...
4090.
Nicht 4900.
4.000...
Äh...
4090.
Wo...
Dass die den Grafikchip abgelötet haben und daraus eigene AI-Acceleration-Boards gebaut
haben in China?
Ach, das ist ein externer...
Ich wollte grad sagen.
Seit wann machen die ihr Netzteil?
Das ist...
Da kann man...
Was auch immer.
Mini-SAS oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung.
Machen.
Aber ich finde das...
Preis-Leistungs-mäßig.
Ja.
Was mich interessieren würde ist...
Was macht der Console-Port?
Das würde mich tatsächlich interessieren.
Hier.
Ähm...
We have two USB-...
Serial...
Serial Console-Port.
Na okay.
Das ist für'n Arsch.
Das braucht ja keiner.
Was ich nice gefunden hätte, ist...
Wenn das Ding noch so'n On-Board-Management-Interface gehabt hätte, aber ich glaub, das kann
man nicht erwarten bei so'ner Kiste.
Management-Interface.
Das kann man nicht erwarten.
Zumal es im Heimbereich jetzt auch weniger schlimm ist, weil im Heimbereich kannst du
einfach schnell ne Tastatur anschließen und gut ist, wenn du mal wirklich gar nicht mehr
drankommst.
Wenn das Ding im Rechenzentrum steht, ist es oftmals schwierig, wenn du nicht grad hinfahren
willst.
Aber coole Hardware.
Ja.
Coole, coole Hardware.
Also, find ich nicht, nicht übel.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich glaube den SSDs sogar, dass die gar nicht so schlecht sind von der
Performance her.
Aber die Haltbarkeit bei den China-S...
Bei den China-SSDs, den trau ich da nicht.
Gut.
Dass die Leistung jetzt keinen so wirklich hinterm Mond hervorlockt, das ist klar.
Aber das muss es ja auch nicht.
Es ist immerhin ein bisschen schneller als diese olle Low-Plattform...
Äh, Low...
Low-Power-Plattform, die ich...
Die ich auch mal hier ne Weile am Start hatte.
Wenn man jetzt mal meine CPU nimmt, ich hab nen Core i9 13900K, glaub ich, also quasi,
tja, sieht man hier gar nicht in der Tabelle, aber, also, meine CPU dürfte einfach mal
zehnmal schneller sein.
Aber ich...
Aber find ich gut.
Wisst ihr...
Jaja.
Äh, find ich nice, das Ding.
Also, die Hardware gefällt mir.
Wenn ich in irgendeiner Art und Weise was brauchen würde, würde ich das considern.
Geiler Satz.
Ähm...
Aber ich brauch grad nichts.
Und einfach nur just for fun ist ja auch blöd, ja.
Wieso gibt es kein OS, dass so ein OS-Stop, wie man bei einer VM...
Au...
Moment, was?
Moment, den Satz versteh ich nicht.
Wieso gibt es kein OS, dass so ein OS-Stop, wie man bei einer VM auslösen kann...
Wo...
Wo alles vom RAM und so auf die...
Ach, so!
Damit könnte man noch eine extrem hohe Geschw...
Hochfahrgeschwindigkeit...
Muss ich...
Das wird doch gemacht.
Ja.
Wollt ich grad sagen.
Das ist, äh...
Hibernate ist was?
S3?
S4?
Ich weiß nicht, wie sich das nennt.
Dafür gibt's ja unterschiedliche...
Power-Off-States.
Und das macht Windows standardmäßig.
Windows macht, glaub ich, sogar mittlerweile Hybrid.
Da speichert die Sachen im RAM für kurzzeitige Sachen, wenn du nur kurz den Laptop zuklappst.
Wenn du nur kurz den Laptop zuklappst, dann...
Wenn du nur kurz den Laptop zuklappst, dann schreibt sie auch gleichzeitig auf die SSD,
dass es schnell erbutet ist.
Gibt's doch!
Gibt's schon!
Was heißt...
Was heißt, gibt's- gibt's- doch...
Gibt's schon ewig?
Gibt's schon 20 Jahre oder so?
Ich mein, dass das nicht...
Oli- Linux kann das auch!
Jaja, Jajaja, Linux kann das auch!
Klar!
Und, das Ding ist halt...
Warum das nicht GANZ so schnell ist...
Wie bei ner VM.
Weil, das Ding ist halt...
Warum das nicht GANZ so schnell ist...
Wie bei ner VM.
Weil, das Ding ist halt...
Warum das nicht GANZ so schnell ist...
Ja, ja, ja, Linux kann das auch, klar.
Und das Ding ist halt, warum das nicht ganz so schnell ist, wie bei einer VM.
Ja, das ist auch relativ, ja, ja, Linux, wie gesagt, Linux kann das auch.
Warum das nicht ganz so schnell ist, wie bei einer VM, ist auch relativ schnell erklärt,
weil der Rechner immer noch ganz normal booten muss.
Die VM, die muss zwar, also einmalig booten, aber die kannst du komplett einfrieren
und es erscheint dann wieder an der Stelle, wo du es ausgeschaltet hast.
Der richtig echte Rechner, der muss ja wirklich booten.
Und das kostet halt auf jeden Fall nochmal 10, 15 Sekunden, je nachdem, wie schnell das alles geladen ist.
Und erst ab dem Punkt, wo das OS von der SSD gestartet wird, ab da kannst du dann schnell laden.
Also, du wirst einen echten Rechner nie so schnell restoren können, durch den ganzen Boot-Prozess, als eine VM.
Bei einer VM geht das ja auch nur.
Weil alles drumherum schon geladen ist und das Ganze emuliert läuft.
Und so eine Windows-Installation, wenn du das mal vergleichst, ist ja auch in einer VM meistens sogar ein Tick,
also bei alten Windows-Systemen, schneller als auf dem Native-System,
weil unten drunter oftmals halt schon der ganze reiberspezifische Kram geladen ist und das schneller funktioniert.
Also, kann man nicht das Booten umgehen, nee.
Wie ein Rechner bootet, ist ziemlich klar festgelegt.
Und da kannst du nicht, nichts umgehen.
Dein Betriebssystem hat beim ersten Einschalten vom Rechner überhaupt nichts zu sagen.
Bei einer VM ist das kein Ding.
Genau, ja.
Du musst, du musst ordentlich booten.
Ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht, wie aktuelles Booten funktioniert.
Aber da gab's ja früher, gab's ja da mehrere Schritte.
Spezielle Adressen, wo was liegen muss, wo im BIOS was passiert, wann.
Ähm, PCI.
Äh, ja.
Wo PCI initialisiert wird, wann RAM ordentlich benutzbar ist, wann hier und da und so.
Da gibt's ja ganz spezielle Sachen.
Und erst, wenn das dann quasi in den Boot-Manager springt
und der Boot-Manager sagt, hey, jetzt starten wir das Betriebssystem.
Ab da kannst du dann erst anfangen, deine eigenen Sachen zu machen.
Und ab da musst du dann ja auch erst mal die, äh, bisschen advanceren Hardware-Treiber laden.
Ja.
Du kannst ja, du kannst ja gar nicht sagen, ey, ich mach jetzt einfach eins zu eins,
ich lade dich einfach mal jetzt in das, in das, in das letzte, in das letzte Image rein.
Du musst ja vielleicht auch erst mal deine Grafikkarte, äh, richtig initialisieren.
Du musst, keine Ahnung, deinen SSD-Treiber laden, äh, der vielleicht standardmäßig nur so ein generic 0815-Zeug geladen hat,
mit dem du anfängst zu booten.
Dann musst du erst mal den, den, den schnellen Kram nachladen.
Dann musst du, äh, alles Mögliche.
Du musst total viel Zeug initialisieren und machen, bis du dann letztendlich überhaupt erst mal deinen Stand,
den du auf die Platte geschrieben hast, laden kannst.
Es geht aber doch verhältnismäßig schnell.
Ich meine, wenn du jetzt mal vergleichst, so ein Rechner früher, der, die, die sind teilweise,
haben die zwei Minuten gebraucht, bis die auf dem Desktop waren.
Heute, selbst mit Festplatten-Vollverschlüsselung, ist das Ding in 20 Sekunden da.
Ke-, kann sich noch einer dran erinnern, wie sich das anhörte, wenn alte Rechner booteten?
Na gut, da gibt's noch, Moment, da gibt's noch bestimmt nen Video, da gibt's noch bestimmt nen Video dazu.
Old PC Booting.
Also das war, das war immer so, wenn die Dinger gestartet sind.
Ja, ja.
Ja, genau.
Also, das war immer so, wenn du den Rechner eingeschaltet hast, lustig das hier,
wenn du den Rechner eingeschaltet hast damals, hast du zwei Sachen gehabt.
Das Ding ist erst mal angegangen, Lüfter, Monitor angegangen.
So, dann ist, dann ist durchgelaufen RAM-Initialisierung.
Dann hat's gemacht, bipp.
Genau, den hat's gemacht, bipp.
Und dann hast du gehört, dann ist die Festplatte angelaufen.
Und allein schon das hat 45 Sekunden gebraucht, bis das alles durch war.
Warte mal, mal gucken, ob wir uns das hier anhören können.
Ja, ja, ja, man hört's, man hört's.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Muss die Musik ausmachen.
Muss die Musik.
Ich bin, ich bin verwirrt.
Ja.
Okay.
Achtung.
OKS.
Ah, ich hab zu viel Zeug auf.
Ich blicke in meinen Tabs nicht mehr durch.
Hier.
Zu viele.
Ja, ich mach das jetzt mal ein bisschen lauter, dass man's hört.
Achtung.
Das war genau das, was ich gerade versucht hab zu beschreiben.
Habt ihr das gehört?
Bipp.
Klick.
Ja.
Oh, wenn ich das sehe.
Normalerweise war da oben immer das Energy Star Symbol.
So.
Ja.
Floppy gab's auch noch.
Wenn man Floppy.
Floppy.
Wobei, das ist schon ein bisschen was Neues.
Das ist ein Pentium 2 oder so, was da drinnen ist.
Ne, was ist da drinnen?
Ja.
Ah, ne.
Noch ein Pentium.
Das ist aber eines der schnellsten Pentiums, die es gibt.
Normaler Pentium.
Ähm.
Leute von heute.
Ja.
Die Zoomers von heute, die kennen das ja auch nicht mehr, dass da so was gekommen ist
wie Detecting HDD Primary.
Man musste damals noch so Jumper setzen an den IDE Festplatten.
Ich bin echt unfähig.
Heute meine.
Meine Tabs zu bedienen.
Ja.
Wer?
Wer kennt's noch?
Ja.
Du hattest dann.
Du hattest dann verschiedene Möglichkeiten, die du stecken konntest mit Jumper.
Das das mit mit mit zwei Jumper war ja schon, war schon super advanced.
Das hat man normalerweise nicht gemacht.
Das hier.
Das hier ist eigentlich eher der Standard gewesen.
Das ist eigentlich eher so der Standard gewesen, dass man so einen Jumper hatte.
Und dann musstest du gucken.
Dass du das in der richtigen Reihenfolge Jumperst.
Denn wenn du nicht aufgepasst hast und zum Beispiel.
Wo haben wir das Video?
Wenn du nicht aufgepasst hast und hast zum Beispiel deine Festplatte als Slave gehabt
und dein CD Laufwerk als Master, dann war die Festplatte, wenn du Pech hattest, langsamer.
Also er hier hat's richtig gemacht.
Die Festplatte als Master, das CD Laufwerk als Slave.
Und wenn du's.
Wenn du's.
Wenn du's als Master gemacht hast, dann hast du das CD Laufwerk quasi an den Secondary IDE angeschlossen.
Und die Festplatten an Primary.
Wie war das mit SCSI Festplatten anders?
Das war so ein.
Das war so.
Das war so ein langes, fettes Kabel.
Wenn ich das richtig schreiben konnte.
Und das muss es ja auch irgendwie terminieren.
Da muss ich dazu sagen, hatte ich nie selbst im Einsatz.
Ich kenne das.
Ich kenne das noch vom Sehen woanders.
Aber ich hatte selbst.
Da bin ich vielleicht ein bisschen dann auch noch zu jung.
Bei mir war das.
H90 nicht mehr angesagt.
SCSI Setup.
Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen.
Das hat bis heute überlebt.
Ja.
Wenn ihr euch SATA anguckt.
Oder den Befehlssatz wie auch M2 SSDs, wobei ich da ein bisschen so aus der mir das jetzt aus dem Ärmel schüttel.
Aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es so ist.
Einige Steuerungssachen aus der Zeit haben es bis heute überlebt.
Selbst für M2 SSDs.
Kommt.
Kommt alles daher.
Ja.
Genau.
Sondern hat es irgendwann.
Übrigens.
Was auch immer witzig war an der Stelle.
Also.
Damals.
Eine Sache, die damals wirklich cool war.
Du konntest dich eigentlich drauf verlassen.
Du bist mit entfernen ins BIOS gekommen.
Heute ist man sich ja dann nicht mehr so sicher, wie man ins BIOS kommt.
Entfernen.
F2.
F12.
Ich mache es mittlerweile so.
Ich kann euch das jetzt nicht vormachen, weil da mein Rechner verrückt spielt.
Ich Face rolle mittlerweile alle F-Keys und entfernen, dass ich auf jeden Fall ins BIOS
komme.
Problem ist, manchmal Face rollt man dann sich auch ins Boot-Menü oder woanders hin,
wo man gar nicht hin will.
Und da muss man doch wieder ausprobieren.
Face rollen.
Quasi einmal mit dem Gesicht über die Tastatur drüber fahren und dann ist alles gedrückt.
Man muss die nicht hämmern.
Ja, ich weiß, ich hämmer die aber trotzdem.
So.
Und was an der Stelle immer nice gewesen ist bei den alten PCs.
Wenn man keine Tastatur angeschlossen hat.
Kam jetzt ein Fehler und da stand, ich kenne den Fehler nicht mehr.
Da stand sinngemäß sowas wie Tastatur keyboard not found.
Press any key to continue.
Das war so eine Standard-Fehlermeldung, die da kam.
Wo man sich so denkt, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wie soll ich F1 drücken ohne Tastatur, Mann?
Oder Press 1, du kommst continue.
Ja, genau.
Press F1.
Genau, sowas gab es dann.
Keyboard not found.
Press F1 to resume oder Press F1 to continue.
Okay, was kommt jetzt?
Zack.
Jetzt greift das, genau, das kann man auch immer.
Okay, jetzt wird auf die Festplatte zugegriffen.
Boot-Menü.
Oh, PXE-Boot konntest du damals schon machen.
Starting Windows 9.
Jetzt macht die Festplatte.
Hört ihr es?
Brrrrt.
Max, fährst du mit dem Rad zur Arbeit?
Nein, aber ich würde gerne.
Aber mein Fahrrad ist ja kaputt seit dem Unfall.
Das ist nicht mehr straßentauglich.
Seht ihr, wie lange der Kram bootet?
Ja.
Ich meine, die Sachen waren damals genügsamer.
Aber das war nicht, also es hat sich schon, gerade Bootgeschwindigkeit und so mäßig, hat sich schon ein bisschen was getan.
Zumal Windows 95 auch bei, wow, mein Auge.
Ah, der schöne Ägypten-Hintergrund.
Wobei Windows 95 ja auch bei weitem, sobald du was gesehen hast und eingeloggt warst, noch nicht fertig war mit starten.
Gut, Windows 10 auch nicht.
Aber Windows 95 war da, war noch größerer Offender in der Richtung.
Ich habe, ich habe letztens gelernt übrigens, man kann hier auch einfach Cancel drücken und es loggt sich trotzdem ein.
Welchen Zweck hatten die Symbole?
Ja, weil es Optik, Optik.
Heute hat man RGB.
Damals hatte man komische Bildschirmschoner und Desktop-Hintergründe.
Tipp, Tipp, Tipp, Tipp.
Ist das, das ist so eine richtig olle, ähm, Klick-Klick-Klick-Tastatur noch.
Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum.
So, und wenn man jetzt denkt, der ist fertig gebootet.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Der ist noch nicht fertig.
Und der ist selbst jetzt noch nicht richtig fertig.
Ihr hört ja die Festplatte.
Ja.
Also, das, das hat, das hat einfach mal.
Mindestens eine Minute gebraucht.
Unfassbar schlecht.
Ah, ne, das ist hier.
Drama.
Drama bei deutschen Hardware-YouTube-Channels.
Habe ich nur am Rande wieder mitbekommen.
Keine Ahnung, was da abgeht.
Und das, das war auch echt so ein Ding.
Der Sache weine ich wirklich nicht nach.
Festplatten-Jumpern.
So sehr Hacker man sich damals fühlen konnte, wenn man das verstanden hat.
Aber der Sache weine ich wirklich nicht nach.
Das finde ich mit SATA doch schon deutlich angenehmer.
Übrigens eine Sache, die ich nie gecheckt habe früher.
Und die eigentlich auch erstmal widersinnig klingt, ist.
Warum ist SATA schneller als IDE?
Bei IDE hast du 40 Pins, um Daten zu übertragen.
Und bei SATA hast du, weiß ich gar nicht, 2 wahrscheinlich.
Um Daten zu übertragen.
Oder 4 oder so.
Strom plus minus.
Ne, wobei das ist was eigenes.
Weiß ich gar nicht.
SATA, wie viele Pins hat man bei SATA?
6?
Ich weiß es nicht.
6, 7.
Zumindest, das habe ich früher nie gecheckt.
Warum, warum man, warum ist SATA schneller als IDE?
Bei IDE hat man noch viel mehr Pins, was zu übertragen.
Das habe ich nicht gecheckt.
Und das ist auch erstmal widersinnig.
Und das kommt alles, auch Captain Toad ist da.
Das kommt alles durch die Schwierigkeit.
Also theoretisch könnte man sagen, ja, IDE ist vom Ansatz her schneller.
Weil du mehrere Sachen parallel übertragen kannst.
Aber sobald du mit den Taktraten hoch gehst, bekommst du Probleme bei paralleler Übertragung, dass alles schön synchronisiert ist.
Und bei serieller Übertragung kannst du mit den Taktraten viel, viel easier hochgehen.
Und dementsprechend kriegst du über SATA mehr drüber.
Ja.
Das ist erstmal widersinnig, dass man sich denkt, hä, wie kann das sein?
Aber aus dem Gesichtspunkt ergibt es dann doch Sinn.
Ja.
Na gut.
Soviel zu old school, old school shit.
HDD-Jumper war noch einfacher.
Auf alten Mainboards musstest du noch Voltage Clocks.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Ja, ja.
Auf meinem Pentium 2.
Ne, ne.
Nicht auf meinem Pentium 2.
Auf meinem allerersten Rechner.
Da hatte ich noch Jumper.
Da hatte ich noch Jumper auf dem Mainboard.
Da konnte man noch Jumpern.
Bei meinem Pentium 2, da habe ich mich, Leute.
Äh, nein.
Dieses Ding.
Da hatte Intel damals die merkwürdige Idee,
die CPUs auf solche komischen, tja, auf solche Cartridges zu packen.
Das hat Intel auch nur in der Pentium 2 Generation gemacht.
Davor und danach nie wieder.
Davor und danach, die Dinger wurden wirklich in so eine Art Slot gesteckt.
Davor und danach war das eigentlich so, wie man es heute kennt.
Zumindest, ich hatte damals ein Pentium 2 400, so ein Teil.
Und ich bin dann, ich bin damals, habe ich, ich weiß nicht, wie ich da drauf gekommen bin.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich von sich, was man sich damals so erzählt hat.
Zumindest, ich bin damals ins BIOS.
Ich kam ja schon wieder Ultra-Hackerman vor, weil ich überhaupt ins BIOS gekommen bin.
So, so, Push, Push, Dell und ins BIOS.
So, und dann habe ich den Frontside-Bus umgestellt.
Von 100 MHz auf 133, glaube ich.
Oder von 200 auf 233.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher.
Und zumindest, lief dann die CPU, anstatt mit 400 MHz, mit 450.
Und ich kam mir so geil vor, weil ich meinen Rechner übertaktet habe.
Und der hat das auch erstaunlich gut verkraftet.
Also, der ist nicht instabil geworden oder sonst was.
Wie alt sind die Leute?
Die Leute im Chat gerade so 18, 18 bis 23, 28.
Ich tippe, die meisten sind zwischen 15 und 60.
Aber falls wir Modkes da haben und sich jemand Bock hat.
Wir haben letztens eine Umfrage gemacht.
Das ist noch gar nicht so alt.
Ja, genau.
25 bis 30 ist der Durchschnitt, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, ja.
Haben wir letztens gemacht.
Ist noch gar nicht so lange her.
Soll ich eine Umfrage machen?
Okay.
Wir machen eine Umfrage.
Moment.
Alles klar.
Paul.
Wie alt seid ihr?
Machen wir unter 18.
Ich mache die Sachen, die ihr vorgeschlagen habt.
18 bis 23.
23 bis 28.
Und was war das andere noch?
28 bis 35.
Nee, wir müssen wenn schon 29 machen, weil ansonsten überschneidet sich das ja.
Und jetzt machen wir älter.
So, additional votes sind nicht erlaubt.
Da gibt es ja keinen Sinn.
Paul ist already active.
Wo?
Was kam raus?
Ich sehe das überhaupt nicht.
Ah.
Die meisten.
Okay.
Alles gut.
Die meisten sind 23 bis 28.
Okay.
Ja, das dachte ich mir.
So in dem Dreh.
Bist halt gestern 30.
Sadge.
Oblos überfordert durch Tabs.
Zumindest.
Ich kam mir halt damals wieder Ultra-Hackerman vor, weil ich, weil ich damals, weil ich
meine CPU übertaktet habe.
Ja.
Und jetzt warte ich mal.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja.
Und jetzt weiß ich, was ich eigentlich war, worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte.
Das war es.
Der hat das geschrieben.
Ja.
Was da Andreas geschrieben hat, was auch noch richtig paint champ damals war, musste jemand
von euch schon mal.
mal Interrupts einstellen auf ISA-Karten. Wir hatten damals eine Fritz-Karte ISA. Ja, so ein
Ding. Und da musste man, ihr seht es hier vielleicht noch, ist leider kein allzu gutes Foto, da musste
man noch hier einstellen, welche Interrupts-Adresse die Karte verwendet, damit sie am Ende auch
funktioniert. Ja, hier sieht man es, hier sieht man es schön. Okay, oben hat man noch Jumper,
Moment, das ist jetzt aber schon PCI, oder? Ne, da kenne ich jetzt gar nicht. Hier, hier sieht man es
wunderbar. Was zum Teufel, von wann ist dieser Artikel? Hier sieht man es gut, genau. Hier muss
man dann, also man musste damals Windows installieren, dann ist man in den Gerätemanager
gegangen, hat sich angeguckt, welcher Interrupt zugewiesen wurde, dann hat man den Rechner
aufgeschraubt und hat den Interrupt an der Karte eingestellt, nur dann ging die Karte. Ganze zwei
Layer. Ey, wir reden hier von, keine Ahnung, 1995 oder so. Ich meine, ihr müsst euch mal das PCB
nachschauen. Hier, ich weiß nicht, was wir da machen, also ich habe nur noch das
Kabel und den Stecker. Hast hier ein paar Widerstände, Kondensatoren-Widerstände, keine Ahnung, ich
erkenne es nicht so richtig. Chat-Gate, was bin ich da sehend? Das ist sehr unscharf. Ionen, ja,
Widerstände. So, hier hast du wahrscheinlich die CPU. Hier hast du irgendeine Uhr oder sowas, könnte das sein? Irgendeine Clock, irgendeine Uhr. Wo hast du den Speicher? Ist das hier der Speicher? Keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, wie es funzt, aber
es ist, es ist vom PC, es ist wirklich
sehr, sehr übersichtlich. Guck mal, du kannst
jeden Pin noch verfolgen
im Endeffekt, wo er hingeht.
Also es ist super übersichtlich gewesen.
Zumindest musste man dort noch
hier die Interrupts
richtig jumpern.
So viel zu uralter Hardware, ja.
Ach, all das,
all das Zeug, all das Zeug weg.
Ja, das, aber
eins muss man sagen, ich fand das
damals sehr cool, weil
man halt noch sehr viel selbst basteln
konnte. Ja, und auch sehr viel
so Hackerman-mäßig
sich richtig auskennen musste mit Hardware,
damit man es auf die Reihe bekommt.
Dankeschön, EDV Forensik für den Sub.
Und es war nicht wirklich schwer.
Ich meine, es konnte im Endeffekt, also du hast
jetzt nicht super großes Gehirn dafür gebraucht,
um zu checken, die Adresse zu
jumpern auf einer Karte, aber das war halt
für den 0815-Loop
komplett jenseits
von
aller Vorstellungskraft, ja, so ein Rechner
aufzuschrauben und so. Ich meine, ich war damals
nicht alt. Ich war damals irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
11, 12 oder so.
Googeln konntest du damals auch
nicht, ja, das war so eher hörend sagen.
So, hier, du musst das, musst das.
Formless TV
Beastmod, dankeschön für den Sub, hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Vivex, danke für den Sub, ich bin total
mittendran und check's nicht.
Stell dir vor, du musstest es irgendeiner Oma
erklären. Damals konntest du auch noch Geld
verdienen, so mit EDV-Service.
Mit IT-Service, so.
Da hatte ich die Oma angerufen
und hat gesagt, also ich hab das nicht gemacht, wie gesagt,
ich war damals
11, 12, aber gab's ja so viele
Bastlerbuden, wo dann die Omas
angerufen haben, ah,
mein PC, die,
oder was heißt die Omas, ja, so die Omas
da hatten damals keinen Rechner, ah, mein PC
startet wieder nicht und wenn sie
grad da sind, gucken sie doch auch mal, ob sie
das erste Programm umlegen
können auf der Fernbedienung und da sind die
Leute hingekommen, haben geguckt, okay,
keine Ahnung, so der Standardfehler,
was war der Standardfehler
damals?
Beim, beim
putzen die Tastatur rausgezogen
aus Versehen oder sowas.
Ich, aber mit anderen IT-Services
als damals. Ich glaube, heute ruft dich keiner
immer an und sagt, ah, Hilfe, mein Rechner bootet
nicht mehr. Und wenn der
Rechner heute nicht bootet, dann liegt's wahrscheinlich daran,
dass billige China-Chinesen-Qualität
ist und du kannst nur was aus...
Ihr macht das immer noch, okay.
Also, das ist auch sowas,
das ist auch so was, das ist auch so was, das ist auch so was,
das hätte ich damals nicht gedacht.
Ich bin ja aufgewachsen so in der Zeit,
wo ich bis, sagen wir mal,
elf, zwölf
Jahren war ich so ganz normales
80er, 90er
Jahre Kind, so mit
draußen und auf dem Campingplatz im
Urlaub, teilweise mit irgendwelchen
Freunden aus der Schule und
draußen rumgestelzt,
Inlineskates gefahren und alle möglichen Sachen.
Da war ich ganz normal
und irgendwann, so mit
zwölf, dreizehn dann,
wo ich den ersten Rechner bekommen hab,
war vorbei. Dann bin ich zum...
Ich setze
vor dem Computer den ganzen Tag
mutiert, so über die nächsten paar Jahre
und in der gleichen
Zeit kam das aber auch auf,
dann immer mehr mit
erstens,
also erstens daheim überhaupt, Computer benutzen
für Office-Sachen, später
Internet, noch später
DSL und solche Geschichten.
Ich hab das quasi so live mitgekriegt
und das fand ich enorm nice, dass ich
so von... Ich hab noch
so ein bisschen so diese ganze
die Pre-Technik,
Pre-IT-Mainstream mitbekommen.
Klar, Computer
und auch Heimcomputer sind älter als
die Zeit, aber das war noch nicht so richtig
krass Mainstream. Zu
386er-Zeiten und sowas und
zu Amiga-Zeiten. Das kam
dann erst so, als ich Jugendlicher
war. Und dann hab ich halt
Internetentwicklung bis heute mitgekriegt.
Ja.
Und damals dachte ich mir, ey,
weißt du was, Max?
Ich verstehe ja, dass die Leute,
die älter sind als du, dazu
keinen Bezug haben und nix checken.
Also Oma, Opa, Eltern
und so, dass die nix checken, verstehe ich
ja, weil die haben ja damit gar nix
am Hut gehabt bis jetzt.
Ja, und die sind auch schon zu alt, um das zu kapieren.
Aber ich hab mir damals immer gedacht,
die Leute, die quasi jetzt
erst auf die Welt kommen,
das hab ich mir dann so 2000 rumgedacht,
also quasi jeder, der nach 2000
geboren ist, wächst damit aus,
und hat automatisch Ahnung davon
und blickt durch. Und da muss ich sagen,
da hab ich mich sehr getäuscht.
Manche Zoomer von heute,
denen trau ich
weniger zu, an ihrem Computer,
an dem Rechner daheim zu machen,
oder generell,
ja, wie soll man sagen, so
intuitives
Verständnis von Technikthemen,
trau ich denen weniger zu,
als den Älteren.
Das hätte ich auch nicht gedacht.
Das hat es, also,
das hätte ich wirklich nicht für möglich gehalten,
dass das tatsächlich
nochmal eine, es war auch nicht die 2000er
Generation, das stimmt nicht, die 2000er
Generation blickt in der Regel wirklich sehr gut
durch, weil da war das Zeug noch nicht so weit.
Aber sagen wir mal, so die 2000,
2010er Generation,
ab 2010, vielleicht,
so, also die, die jetzt so
14 sind, es ist unglaublich,
wie wenig Durchblick die Leute
da teilweise haben. Das siehst du
auf Reddit, wenn du dir da irgendwelche,
hier, Hilfe, Hilfe, mein PC
macht komische Dinger, Sachen anguckst, oder
oder hier, wie, wie kann
ich, wie kann ich VPN
machen auf iPhone und solche Geschichten?
Oder wie, oder wie kann ich kostenlos
Film gucken? Und da denkst du dir,
was ist mit den Leuten los, man, wie unfähig
kann man sein heutzutage?
Wobei ich denke, in der, in der Summe
gibt es trotzdem mehr, die durchblicken.
Bin gespannt, wie es morgen losgeht,
wegen, ach, jetzt wieder Bahnstreik oder was?
Oder was meinst du? Ich hab überhaupt nichts mitbekommen,
warum? Ja, ey, solche Dinger
wundern mich, wundern mich nicht.
Es gibt Leute, die schreiben
unironisch, warum
kann man den Fehler nicht
im Screenshot erkennen, so. Also, die haben
einen Pixelfehler im Display,
die schreiben, mein Display ist kaputt,
ich mach euch mal ein Screenshot.
Und dann machen sie Screenshot und posten den Screenshot
und dann sagen sie, ey,
warum sieht man auf, auf Screenshot nicht,
dass das Bildschirm kaputt ist?
Wenn, wisst ihr, wenn wir
sowas posten würden, wir, wir würden das so,
als Debate posten. Wir würden das
als Debate posten. Aber die meinen das
ernst. Die meinen das wirklich ernst,
die Leute. Die machen Screenshot,
die, die, die haben Pixelfehler
oder vielleicht sogar ein gebrochenes Display,
machen ein Screenshot und wundern sich, warum ist
das nicht im Screenshot drauf?
Ich weiß nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Von jeder Generation gibt es eine gewisse,
einen gewissen technikaffinen
Anteil, die das, die das interessiert,
wie es funktioniert und die dann sich auch später damit
beschäftigt. Aber ich glaube,
die, die richtig
Technik, die Technik
Boomer-Generation, wo, wo, wo ich
jetzt nicht meine Boomer im Brain, sondern halt
da, wo, wo es anteilmäßig besonders
viele Technikinteressierte gab,
das war meine Generation und die danach,
angefangen mit der
davor, aber
danach
ist, glaube ich, echt anteilmäßig wieder ein bisschen
zurückgegangen.
Die machen einen Screenshot mit dem Handy. Ja klar machen
die einen Screenshot mit dem Handy und wundern sich
dann, warum man den Display, Displayfehler nicht drauf
sieht. Denn ist der Zusammenhang nicht
klar zwischen Display und
Screenshot, dass der Screenshot quasi
den Rahmen von einer Grafikkarte
snapshotet, sozusagen
billig gesagt und
ein Display halt kaputt sein kann,
aber der Rahmen von einer Grafikkarte, wo der Bild, wo
das Bild, die Bildinfos drin sind, in Ordnung
ist. Das verstehen die nicht. Die denken
Bildschirm hat einen Fehler.
Ach, du meinst, die machen ein Foto mit einem
anderen Handy. Ne, Handy bedienen
können die Leute. Die machen einen Screenshot mit dem
Handy. Das stimmt schon.
Wobei man bei Autos sagen muss, dass ich bei
Autos enorm viel geändert hat.
Ich hab's gemerkt. Ich hab mir ein neues Auto gekauft.
Wisst ihr ja, letztes Jahr im August.
Und ich bin gewechselt von, also für alle, die
das, ich zeig das nochmal kurz, weil ich
nicht mitbekommen bin. Ich bin gewechselt von einem
Opel Agila 2001
oder so in grün.
Ja, mehr oder weniger der hier war
das, mein Auto, mein altes Auto.
Bin ich gewechselt
zu einem Fiat 500e.
So, und jetzt
vergleichen wir mal
Cock, yep, Cockpit.
So, jetzt vergleicht mal das
hier
mit dem da.
Ne, fast.
So ähnlich. Sieht schon.
Und das ist tatsächlich,
der hat sogar hier unten schon ein Radio
mit CD und sowas drin. Das ist schon ein bisschen
neuerer. Vielleicht soll ich 2001 reinmachen.
Also 1 zu 1.
Also, so ähnlich.
So ähnlich sah das aus, bis auf das Radio.
So, ich mein, seriously.
Ja, doch. Doch.
Bis auf den Radio.
Jetzt vergleicht halt mal das Ding
mit
dem Teil.
Ist halt schon einfach mal
20 Jahre
Entwicklung dazwischen. Und in diesen
20 Jahren ist halt nicht nur
das Auto an sich
moderner geworden, sondern auch die Technik drin.
Und
da muss ich auch sagen, ey,
ich musste auch ein bisschen
gucken, was jetzt was macht.
Weil das ist ja auch nicht unbedingt
alles super
intuitiv.
Intuitiv gelöst. Zum Beispiel
das Steuern der Klimaanlage hier drüber
ist nicht sonderlich intuitiv.
Du hast einen Auto-Button.
Du hast einen
Button, um das ein- und auszuschalten.
Der ist da drüben.
Das Problem ist, wenn du
Auto switchst und manuellen Betrieb,
dann nimmt er manchen State mit und manchen
State nicht. Das ist teilweise recht weird
gemacht.
Außerdem ist es ein bisschen doof, muss ich sagen,
dass die Bedienelemente
der Klimaanlage da unten sind. Ich mein,
okay, hier beim Agile hattest du keine
Klimaanlage. In dem Sinne, du hattest eine Heizung.
Da konntest du hier an dem Rad drehen und
dann ist es warm geworden. Du musstest
noch... Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wo das ist.
Du musstest... Irgendwo musstest du noch einschalten.
Keine Ahnung. Hier. Hier neben war das.
Hier musstest du noch einschalten. Musstest du quasi da hochdrehen
und dann konntest du hier zack. Das war simpel.
Was ich ein bisschen blöd finde, für meinen
Geschmack, ist die Bedienung.
Vielleicht kann man es ein bisschen
größer machen. Das ist aber nicht das
richtige Bild.
Doch, ist es.
Für meinen Geschmack
ist tatsächlich
die Buttons ein Tick weit
zu weit unten,
weil man guckt hier raus
und man muss dann so...
Man muss doch schon ein bisschen weit nach unten
gucken, sodass man kaum noch im
Augenwinkel was sieht. Zumal die Knöpfe
nicht sonderlich intuitiv sind, muss man
da auch ein bisschen länger drauf gucken, als mir
lieb ist. Also das ist tatsächlich nicht
so schön gemacht. Das Gute ist,
man kann die Klimaanlage auch
steuern per Voice Commands.
Da braucht man dann gar nichts mehr. Man kann
hier auf dem Display Voice Commands
starten oder man kann sagen
Hey Fiat! Wobei,
das finde ich immer cringe, mit meinem Auto so zu reden.
Da kann man dann auch sagen, Hey Fiat,
Klimaanlage an. Oder man kann auch sagen,
es ist mir zu warm und sowas und dann
regelt er das runter. Aber ich drücke
tatsächlich am liebsten Knöpfchen.
Was das angeht. Das hier unten ist
auch nice. Hier kannst du das Handy reinlegen
und das Handy lädt auf. Das hat so Induktions
Ladungszeug
dafür.
Ja und das hier ist die Gangschaltung
beim Elektroauto.
Also du hast keine Gangschaltung mehr.
In dem Sinn. Beim Agila hat es die ja in der Mitte
noch. Du hast ja im Prinzip
keine Gangschaltung mehr. Du brauchst
eigentlich nur den Gang hier. Drive.
Es gibt im Prinzip vier
Gänge. Du hast für Parken,
Rückwärts, Leerlauf
und Vorwärts.
Also im Prinzip stellst du eigentlich immer auf
Drive und sonst nix. Ab und zu mal auf
Rückwärts, wenn du Rückwärts fahren willst.
Und Parken musst du gar nicht machen.
Parken macht er automatisch, wenn du
ausschaltest.
Also ich muss halt sagen, es ist ein
riesen Unterschied technologisch. 20 Jahre
Entwicklung. Und in den 20 Jahren
2000 bis 2022
ist enorm viel passiert.
Elektroniktechnisch im Auto. Der hatte
noch kein Display. Der hat ein ordentliches
halbwegs hochauflösendes Display.
Und
man muss sich echt ein bisschen
dran gewöhnen. Kupplung gibt's nicht mehr.
Nur noch
Gas und Bremsen. Kann der auch
ein Pedal? Ja, kann er auch.
Also ein Pedal ist
der bremst quasi,
wenn du vom Gaspedal runter gehst, automatisch
und lädt damit den Akku wieder ein bisschen.
Da kann man ein
Pedal Driven, wenn man will.
Jetzt bin ich nicht mehr agil
unterwegs. Und da
muss ich sagen, wenn das sogar für mich
mal ein bisschen dauert, bis ich alle
Funktionen da gecheckt habe.
Was man da machen kann.
Wie ist das dann erst für jemand, der
überhaupt nicht technikaffin ist
und umsteigt
von so einem Auto auf so
ein Auto.
Der ist doch komplett,
der weiß doch nicht mal, wie man einschaltet, oder?
Stellt euch mal vor,
du bist so ein
bis 80-jähriger Opa
und du wechselst von so einem Auto
zu so einem Auto. Du bist lost
komplett.
Wofür N? Leerlauf.
Wenn du zum Beispiel
in ne Waschanlage
fährst, wo du so durchgezogen wirst,
machst du das?
Wisst ihr, es gibt
doch so Waschanlagen, da fährst du rein und
fädelst dich so ein und dann wirst du durchgezogen.
Bedienungsanleitung,
die Bedienungsanleitung ist shit.
Die Bedienungsanleitung
ist shit.
Ich muss dir aber ehrlich sagen,
ich spreche
da nur theoretisch,
ich war mit dem Ding noch nicht in ner Waschanlage
so in so ner, wenn wir durchgehen,
durchgezogen Waschanlage.
Ich habe N, legit,
noch nicht verwendet
mit diesem Auto.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es das ist,
was ich dir gerade gesagt hab.
Sicher bin ich mir nicht.
Oder wenn man abgeschleppt wird,
ja genau, zum Beispiel.
Der Fiat Champ
Der Fiat Champ ist ein Must-Have
für Besitzer solch eines Autos, habe ich gehört.
Richtig, richtig.
Der Fiat Champ ist wichtig.
Was kann der Fiat Champ alles?
Wurde das schon beantwortet?
Damit kannst du Daten
von deinem Auto in Home Assistant übertragen.
Ist wohl ein merkwürdiger
Entwickler, der das mal programmiert hat.
Ja, muss man sagen, dass so ein komischer Typ
auf GitHub, hier Fiat
Fiat Champ
Das ist so ein
so ein komischer Wubblos,
der das mal gebastelt hat.
Zuletzt aktualisiert,
Dezember 2022,
zwei Jahre.
Und
keine bekannten Issues.
Alles Bedienfehler.
Keine bekannten Issues.
Ja.
Naja.
Aber so viel zum Umstieg
von Auto, was überhaupt keine
Computertechnik-Kramsachen
am Start hat,
zu doch was halbwegs modernem.
Ich meine, wenn man das nochmal mit einem neuen Tesla
vergleicht, ist das wahrscheinlich nochmal
eine Nummer mehr Technik drin.
Auf deinem Tesla kannst du ja sogar Steam starten,
habe ich gehört.
Was du nicht mal starten kannst, ist auf modernen Teslas,
ist wohl die Disney-App.
Kann das jemand bestätigen?
Ich habe das nur letztens gelesen,
dass Elon hat sich ja gestritten,
mag ja Disney nicht mehr.
Und anscheinend wurde dann die Disney-App
von Teslas runtergeschmissen.
Wie sind die Kosten im Vergleich?
Boah.
Ich kann es enorm schwer vergleichen,
wie die Kosten sind.
Theoretisch, weil ich das Elektroauto zu
99% daheim lade,
würde ich vermuten, sind die
Kosten etwas geringer,
wobei man halt sagen muss, dass
Benzinpreise
wieder ein bisschen runtergegangen
sind und Strompreise und sowas
alles extrem gestiegen ist.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das
so viel günstiger ist.
Ey, keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich ist es schon ein bisschen
günstiger.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie viel
und ich will mich jetzt auch nicht
auf ein Fenster lehnen oder was.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Und es ist auch enorm schwierig,
gerade jemanden zu bekommen,
nicht nur der das machen kann,
sondern auch das zu planen
ist enorm schwierig.
Also, habe ich nicht.
Dann würde es sich tatsächlich
deutlich besser rechnen.
Aber
man muss sich ja auch
die Anschaffungskosten von
Solarpanels und alles mit einrechnen.
Das ist ja auch, also unter 20.000 Euro
für eine Installation auf dem Dach
kommst du ja da wahrscheinlich nicht weg.
Also, das ist schon nicht ohne.
Ja, muss man auch.
Und nachdem Elektroauto
noch deutlich teurer ist,
gerade bei mir, weil ich es neu angeschafft habe,
obwohl das alte ein paar Macken gemacht hat,
aber eigentlich noch ging,
hat es erstmal sehr viel Kohle gekostet.
Ob es langfristig günstiger wird,
weil weniger Wartung und Probleme
fallen, das muss ich noch zeigen.
Theoretisch ja, praktisch
mal gucken.
So.
Jetzt machen wir das mal zu.
Genug geschwätzt, was können wir uns denn
heute auf YouTube angucken?
Linux on Macs.
Okay, guck mal hier.
Wir gucken hier.
Das Ding ist halt, die meisten Leute,
die einen Mac haben,
wollen darauf doch gar keinen Linux haben, oder?
Wer sich einen Mac kauft,
ist so Mac OS und Apple affin,
dass sie keinen Linux drauf installieren, oder?
Gibt es Leute, die das machen?
Also ich würde es machen,
weil ich keinen Bock auf Mac OS hätte,
aber ich würde mir auch gar keinen Mac erst kaufen.
Also mal angenommen,
mir würde irgendeiner einen Macbook in die Hand drücken
und sagen, Max, du musst arbeiten mit dem Macbook,
dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich Linux drauf installieren,
wenn ich könnte.
Und wenn das nicht geht, würde ich Mac OS
mehr oder weniger terminal only benutzen
mit den Linux Sachen, die ich kenne,
was ja unter Mac OS glücklicherweise ganz gut geht.
Ja, klar, natürlich, easy.
Dazu müsste man sich erstmal damit beschäftigen.
Montage ist teuer, ja klar.
So, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Macbook.
What the fuck?
Warum das so anders aussieht?
Weil da Linux drauf läuft.
Und ich finde das schon relativ cool.
Guck mal hier.
Ist das denn auch Arch Linux?
Ich habe das Fedora Logo gesehen.
Habt ihr auch das Fedora Logo gesehen?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Macbook.
What the fuck?
Warum das so anders aussieht?
Ja, ja, ja,
ich habe da ein Fedora Logo gesehen.
Weil da Linux drauf läuft.
Und ich finde das schon relativ cool.
Also mit diesem animierten Hintergrund hier.
Aber muss man natürlich nicht machen,
wenn man das so hektisch findet mit dem Hintergrund.
Kann man auch ganz anders machen.
Ja, logisch.
Denn das ist ja gerade der Punkt bei Linux,
dass man alles so hinfrickeln kann,
wie man das kann.
Und das funktioniert.
Mit Linux und MacOS.
Du hast recht, Freddy.
Da habe ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht.
Wenn man ein altes Macbook hat,
mit nicht mal so Porte der MacOS-Version drauf,
da kann das durchaus Sinn machen.
Weil die Hardware ist ja oftmals noch,
sagen wir mal, potent genug.
Guck mal, Tim Apple.
Das hat natürlich auch viele Vorteile.
Aber ist doch super,
dass man jetzt beide Welten haben kann.
Auf Apple Rechnern.
In diesem Video zeige ich euch,
wie gut das schon funktioniert mit Asahi Linux auf Macs.
So heißt das Projekt.
Und was eben noch nicht so gut funktioniert.
Und wofür das überhaupt gut sein soll.
Und wir zeigen euch natürlich auch,
wie man das installiert.
Erinnert mich vom Namen her ein bisschen dran.
Wie hieß denn dieses Zeug,
wo man früher mit IPv4
alle auto-generated IP-Adressen
zugewiesen hat.
Das hieß nicht Asahi.
Das hieß doch auch
dieser Standard.
Das heißt doch fast genauso.
Nee.
Avahi? Avahi meine ich.
Ja, Avahi.
Free Zero Configuration
Network Implementation.
Ja, das meine ich. Avahi, nicht Asahi.
Das sind diese
169er IP-Adressen.
Ja, genau.
Diese 169
169 irgendwas.
Ja.
Und wofür das überhaupt gut sein soll.
Und wir zeigen euch natürlich auch,
wie man das installiert.
Ist echt relativ einfach.
Und ihr macht nichts kaputt.
MacOS bleibt drauf.
Ihr könnt also wählen, was ihr booten wollt.
Und man kann natürlich auch den
Ursprungszustand herstellen.
Bleibt dran.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von
Bitdefender Total Security.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
was ich besser finden soll.
Bitdefender Total Security oder NordVPN?
Total Security.
Das ist eine Software, die eure Geräte
sehr ressourcenschonend, mehrschichtig
schützt und viele unterschiedliche
Angriffsformen bekämpft. Unter anderem
Ransomware.
Okay, seriously, wenn die mir
genug Kohle geben würden, ich würde da auch ein Sponsoring machen.
Und genau das sagen,
was sie sagen, was sie wollen,
dass ich sage. Ich sag nur dazu,
ich war noch nie in einer Wüste.
Das sollte ich so sagen,
also habe ich so gesagt.
Und Zero-Day-Exploits.
Außerdem erkennt Bitdefender Total Security
unerlaubte Zugriffe auf Webcam
und Mikrofon. Ja, und blockt die natürlich auch.
Die Software läuft auf Windows,
MacOS, Android und IOS.
Also egal, was ihr so benutzt, ihr seid
auf der sicheren Seite. Mehr dazu in der Beschreibung.
Und wenn ihr den Link dort verwendet,
bekommt ihr 50% Rabatt
auf Bitdefender Total Security.
Werbung Ende.
So, bevor es richtig losgeht...
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Wo es gerade um cringige Werbung geht.
Falls irgendjemand das Video nicht gesehen hat.
Ich mache jetzt noch einmal
kostenlos Werbung für Genshin Impact.
Ich fand das so...
So Pelz-Champ.
So.
Ich habe letztes Jahr
habe ich mal ein Sponsoring gemacht.
Für Genshin Impact.
Und das sah so aus.
Vielleicht, wer sich das Ganze doch noch
kaufen sollte, das erzähle ich euch gleich.
Und das bringt mich auch zum Partner
des heutigen Videos. Genshin Impact ist ein
Open-World-Adventure-Game mit einer großen Anzahl
verschiedener Charaktere...
Runtergerattert, Mann.
Genshin Impact ist für PS5, PS4,
PC, auch für Mobilgeräte, IOS,
und Android erhältlich. Die große, atmosphärische,
offene Welt lädt dich ein, tiefer zu erforschen.
Eine Welt voller Geheimnisse, in der es sieben
Regionen, sieben Götter, und wie könnte es anders sein,
auch sieben Elemente gibt, die kombiniert werden können,
um neue Synergien zu schaffen und noch mehr
coole Angriffe auszuführen. Die geschlossene
Karte von Genshin, wenn man nur Mondstadt,
Leo, Sumero mitzählt, ist mehr als 5.900
Fußballfelder in der realen Welt.
Das Spiel hat regelmäßige Inhaltsupdates
für den kürzlich veröffentlichten Patch 3.1,
der neue, aufregende Regionen
wie Sumero mit einem neuen Wüstengebiet bringt.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste, aber ich kann
die geheimnisvolle Wüste
Ich war noch nie
in einer Wüste
Das ist jetzt so dumm, Alter.
...regionen wie Sumero
mit einem neuen Wüstengebiet bringt.
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste, aber ich kann
die geheimnisvolle Wüste, die alten Ruinen
in Sumero erkunden. Und es gibt drei
neue Helden im Spiel. Sino, ein
5-Sterne-Elektro, Kanons, ein 4-Sterne-Hydro,
beide recht mächtig, und schließlich
Nilou, ein... Recht mächtig!
Die wollten, die wollten, dass ich
sage, recht mächtig.
Das stand explizit in dieser
äh, wie heißt das, in dieser
Briefing-E-Mail drin. Ich sollte sagen,
recht mächtig.
5-Sterne-Hydro recht mächtig mit einem
Schwert. Zusätzlich zu den liebevoll
gestalteten Anime-Visuals bietet
jeder Charakter seine eigene spannende
Hintergrundgeschichte und eine möglichst tiefgreifende
Interaktion mit der Spielwelt. Zur Feier
des Updates auf Version 3.1 zeigt
Genshin Impact die Geschichte der Spieler in Genshin
in Offline-Werbung auf der ganzen Welt.
In Deutschland werden die Erinnerungsspieler
im Münchner Hauptbahnhof gezeigt.
Ich empfehle euch also, einen Blick darauf zu werfen,
wenn ihr in der Nähe seid. Scanne den QR-Code
oder sieh dir meinen Download-Link
zum Spiel zum Endless Journey Event in der Beschreibung
an. Wenn du diesen Code im Spiel verwendest,
kannst du auch...
Ja, alles gut, Max.
Oh, Mann.
Ich hab mir
gedacht, ich mach mal ein Sponsoring. Die haben halt mit
Geld gewedelt, ja.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Oh, Mann.
Das grinscht mich selbst,
wenn ich mir das anhören muss.
Wie viele Knete gab es?
Ich weiß nicht mehr
genau. Keine Ahnung.
Moment.
Ich hab doch letztens
erst die Steuern gemacht.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Google Drive?
Da muss ich mein Passwort eingeben. Ja, nee.
Da nicht. Da kann ich jetzt nicht nachgucken.
Ich bin nicht eingeloggt
auf dem zweiten Rechner. Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher.
Ich sag euch jetzt mal ungefähr was,
wo ich glaube, dass
das... Ich glaube 2500 Euro.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher. So in dem
Dreh.
Die haben pünktlich überwiesen.
Mit denen hab ich sogar mehrere Sachen gemacht.
Ja. Ich glaube 2500 Euro.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher, ob es das...
Aber ich glaube, das war Genshin Impact.
Ich kann mich
nämlich noch dran erinnern, dass die
sieben E-Mails geschrieben haben mit
Briefing
Material und
irgendwelchem
Code Zeug,
was dann erst falsch generiert war,
was ich hinzufügen... Ich glaube 2500 Euro.
Also ich finde, dafür
kann man schon mal
dafür kann man schon mal eineinhalb Minuten
sagen, dass man nicht in der Wüste war.
Das ist natürlich im Vergleich was andere für ein
Sponsoring kriegen wieder der Witz, aber
für meine Sache ist das glaube ich echt
ganz okay.
Kannst du raten, wie viel vom Gesamtumsatz
das sind?
Ne, weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, aber auf jeden Fall
nicht unerheblicher Teil, weil
ich mach so wenig auf YouTube,
dass ich mit Adsense an sich nicht viel Geld
bekomme,
mit Amazon nicht viel Geld bekomme,
mit meinen Guides
Affiliate Links auch nicht viel Geld bekomme.
Also wird das wahrscheinlich schon
weiß ich nicht
15, 15 Prozent
oder so ausgemacht haben, weil dieses Jahr
habe ich schon, also dieses Jahr, wo ich
das Genshin Sponsoring gemacht habe, habe ich ja noch
tatsächlich einiges
an anderen Sponsorings gemacht und auch relativ
viel hochgeladen. Ich muss sagen so 15,
15 Prozent oder sowas.
Na, mehr, mehr, mehr.
Das stimmt nicht, das stimmt nicht.
Mehr.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
eher sogar 20, 25, na 20,
20 Prozent, 20 Prozent.
20 Prozent, dann kann man das mal fünf
Rechnen. Ja, dann kommt das
ungefähr hin.
Und dann ein bisschen Twitch drauf.
Ich könnte es euch jetzt relativ
genau sagen, weil ich habe die, ich habe
diese ganzen Sachen für die Steuererklärung
fertig gemacht letztens, aber ich bin
leider nicht eingeloggt auf den zweiten Rechner.
Ja, das ist ein Top-Stundenlohn
dafür, für ein bisschen sinnlos.
Aber da hängt tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr hinten dran.
Ich habe das bestimmt fünf Mal aufgenommen,
bis es ihnen gefallen hat, weil am Anfang
wisst ihr, wisst ihr, am Anfang habe ich mir
gedacht, ich mache das in nicht ganz
so cringe. Dann habe ich mir ein paar
Punkte genommen, die man in eineinhalb Minuten
reinpacken konnte und habe
das möglichst in meinem
Style möglichst, sagen wir mal,
ja, einladend, das auszuprobieren,
dass das nett klang,
eingesprochen. Ich fand das eigentlich
gar nicht schlecht, aber da meinte die
Agentur, die dieses Sponsoring
gemacht hat, nee, da sind zu wenig Punkte drin.
Und er hätte einen Textvorschlag
für mich. Und da haben die mir einen Textvorschlag
geschickt von einer, den er vier
Seite, was ich in neunzig Sekunden
sagen sollte. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr schon mal
eine DNA4-Seite in neunzig Sekunden
vorgelesen habt, in Schriftgröße zwölf
oder was das war. Aber das ist nicht,
not possible in neunzig Sekunden.
Und dann habe ich
halt ein paar Sachen rausgestrichen
und habe halt
den ganzen Krempel
möglichst emotionslos
runtergerattert und die Bilder
reingemacht von dem, was sie sehen wollten.
Die hatten ja eine genaue Anforderung,
wo das Logo sein soll, dass man die
Bonusgegenstände zeigen soll und alles.
Und dann ist gut.
Letztendlich ist die Werbung deutlich schlechter
gewesen, aus meiner Sicht,
als die erste Version, die ich aufgenommen habe.
Also deutlich weniger authentisch
und hat aus meiner Sicht auch
weniger Leute angesprochen. Aber wenn
sie das so wollen, sie bezahlen den Kram am Ende.
Mache ich das so. Und ich gehe
davon aus, dass die Agentur
wiederum selbst genaue Vorgaben
von Genshin, wie heißt denn der?
Wie heißt denn der Hersteller?
Vom Genshin
Impact Video.
Vom Genshin Impact
Hersteller hatte, was da rein soll.
Raid habe ich bis jetzt noch
nie gemacht. Raid hatte ich auch schon ein paar Anfragen,
aber Raid Shadow Legends ist echt nicht so das Ding,
das ich bewerben wollte.
Gut, schauen wir mal weiter.
Linux auf Macs.
Kurz in eigener Sache. Den Mail-Newsletter
vom CT3003-Team namens Hype,
den kennt ihr ja hoffentlich schon.
Jetzt gibt es noch ein Newsletter von unserem
Kameramedium, der richtigen CT.
Direkt aus der Chefredaktion.
Ich bin eigentlich total blöd.
Ich habe seit 20 Jahren oder so ein CT-Abo.
Länger.
Seit fast 25 Jahren ein CT-Abo.
In Offline-Form.
Ich kriege alle 14 Tage ein CT geschickt.
Und ich habe die letzten
10 Jahre
wahrscheinlich
davon 3 Artikel gelesen.
... von Thorsten und Jan
mit so hinter den Kulissen-Infos.
So, jetzt aber
endlich Asahi-Linux.
Die Version, die wir getestet haben,
ist die erste stabile Version
rausgekommen Ende Dezember 2023.
Die erste Alpha kam
ungefähr 1,5 Jahre vorher raus
und die habe ich auch installiert, aber mit der konnte
man wirklich noch nicht so richtig viel anfangen.
Die war noch auf Arch-Linux-Basis,
die jetzt veröffentlichte Version ist auf Basis
des altehrwürdigen Fedora.
Wie, und das soll besser sein?
Arch-Linux,
Leute, die haben Arch-Linux
durch Fedora ersetzt. Was ist da los?
Kann ja schon mal nix taugen.
Soll ich jetzt
erzählen, ich benutze Fedora, by the way,
oder wie?
Also der Distribution, die auch
der Linux-Erfinder Linus Torvalds
verwendet. Ganz wichtig, habe ich noch gar nicht
gesagt. Linus selbst verwendet nicht
Arch-Linux. Soll ich davon jetzt halten?
Ist etwa der Linux-Erfinder
auch ein Noob?
Wir wissen doch alle,
Arch-Linux ist einfach
superior. Eventuell
eventuell noch
selbstkompiliertes Gentoo, das lasse ich,
oder Gentoo, wie das ja man sagt, das lasse ich mir noch
gefallen. Aber alles andere, ne.
Man muss nix hacken auf Macs,
um Asahi Linux installieren zu können.
Obwohl der Asahi-Hauptentwickler
Hector Martin alias Mark
Khan unter anderem die Nintendo
Wii und mehrere Playstations gehackt
hat. Also das ist tatsächlich von Apple
beim Design der Apple-Silicon-
Plattform, also den Nicht-Intel-
Macs, also M1, M2 und M3-Prozessor
so vorgesehen, dass man
unsigniertes Zeugs booten
kann. Nur gab's vor Asahi halt nix,
was man hätte booten können.
Das ganze System ist tatsächlich
sicherheitstechnisch sehr interessant gelöst und funktioniert
ziemlich anders als
Das haut wahrscheinlich
Apple bei einer nächsten
Revision raus, sollte das nennenswerten
Zuspruch finden.
Man kann auf Apple-Silicon-Maschinen
zum Beispiel nicht von externen Datenträgern
booten, nur von den eingebauten
SSDs. Und wenn man das
unsigniertes booten will, bleibt das
Hauptbetriebssystem, also macOS,
immer komplett abgeschottet davon.
Und Asahi Linux ist echt ne gute
Nachricht für Linux-Leute, die
ihr Lieblingsbetriebssystem zum Beispiel gerne
auf schöner Notebook-Hardware
laufen lassen wollen. Denn egal wie man
zu Apple steht, das kann man schon objektiv
sagen, dass vor allem die Macbooks
sehr hochwertig sind. Mit schönen, stabilen
Metallgehäusen, super Displays,
lüfterlosen Design beim MacBook Air
und vor allem viel Leistung
bei langer Akkulaufzeit.
Aber Asahi Linux läuft natürlich
auch auf stationären Apple-Silicon-
Rechnern, also Mac Mini, iMac
oder Mac Studio. Nur der Mac Pro
wird noch nicht unterstützt.
Ja, okay, aber wie läuft denn das jetzt?
Ja, ziemlich gut. Ich war auf jeden Fall
positiv überrascht, dass
Apple-Silicon-Maschinen
in den letzten Jahren
ein bisschen besser
gelaufen sind.
Ich war überrascht von der Smoothness
von Asahi. Out of the box funktioniert
zum Beispiel WLAN, Bluetooth, die eingebaut sind.
Also wie das gemeint war, ich würde sagen,
es war genau so gemeint, wie er es gesagt hat.
Du kannst nicht von
USB-Sticks oder externen Platten booten.
Lautsprecher bei Macbooks,
die Kameras und ich konnte auch auf meinem
MacBook Air mit M.2-Prozessor völlig
problemlos... Also wenn sofort das WLAN geht,
das ist schon mal ein großer Pluspunkt. Das war ja
lange Zeit unter Linux
ein ziemlicher Painpoint, wie man
sowas so schön nennt.
Das Schöne an MacBooks ist wahrscheinlich,
dass man halt einen Treiber braucht, der
funktioniert und der geht dann auf allen, weil
da die gleiche Hardware drin ist.
Mit den Hell-Dunkel-Tasten die Bildschirmhelligkeit
einstellen. Die Darstellung und Qualität ist
super, Text sieht schön scharf aus,
Scrolling im Browser ist geschmeidig.
Wer kauft so eine zugenagelte Hardware?
Das kannst du im MacOS-Ökosystem
bei allem fragen.
Mac funktioniert mit Mac gut,
aber die Leute, die da draufstehen, kaufen das.
Installiert ist übrigens Firefox.
Also ja, es gibt Asahi in mehreren Versionen... Du könntest genauso gut fragen,
wer kauft sich ein Smartphone,
wo du bei jedem Furz dir ein neues
kaufen musst, wenn was ist, aber
ich habe auch ein iPhone.
Ich unter anderem.
Und einmal mit dem etwas mit Windows und Mac ähnlicherem KDE Plasma
als grafischer Benutzeroberfläche
und einmal mit Gnome, das ist dann etwas spezieller.
Außerdem gibt es auch Varianten ganz ohne
grafische Oberfläche. Gnome sagt auch.
Ich habe die Variante mit KDE Plasma getestet.
Ich brauche i3.
Ist das Wayland, was sie da verwenden?
Wayland oder noch X?
Weil i3 ist ja unter Wayland nicht da.
Da musst du Sway verwenden.
Was ich direkt richtig gelungen fand...
Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Asahi Linux?
Ist das Wayland oder was ist das?
Wayland oder X11?
Aha.
Asahi Linux warnt vor Nutzung von X11.
Hä?
Ja wie jetzt?
Also sie benutzen, die mögen X nicht benutzen,
aber trotzdem X.
Jetzt checke ich es nicht so ganz, aber okay.
Zumindest ist die Frage,
kann man da drauf i3 laufen lassen?
Ja, kann man.
Guck mal hier.
Nice.
Damit könnte ich mir sogar vorstellen, Macbook zu verwenden.
Wenn man unten auf Akku klickt,
kann ich mit einem Klick direkt sagen,
dass das System nicht in den Ruhezustand gehen soll.
Was ist i3?
Das hier ist i3.
Mein...
Nicht wirklich das animierte Anime GIF.
Meine Desktop Oberfläche unter Linux.
Wobei es kein Desktop ist, weil ich habe keinen Desktop.
Mach doch Sway.
Ja, aber unter X nicht.
Sonst ein Wayland.
In der VRM mache ich garantiert nicht Sway,
weil da funktioniert Wayland nicht richtig.
Also, das ist i3.
Dieser Window Manager hier.
Der keine Windows hat.
Außer hier.
Ups, was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Okay, Quade.
Moment, wo waren wir denn?
...design beim Macbook Air
und vor allem...
Einmal mit dem etwas Windows und Mac
ähnlicheren Hell-Dunkel-Tasten
die Bildschirmfähigkeit einstellen.
Die Darstellungsqualität ist super.
Text sieht schön scharf aus.
Scrolling im Browser ist geschmeidig.
Vorinstalliert ist übrigens Firefox.
Also ja, es gibt Asahi in mehreren Versionen.
Einmal mit dem etwas Windows und Mac
ähnlicherem KDE Plasma
als grafischer Benutzeroberfläche
und einmal mit GNOME.
Das ist dann etwas spezieller.
Außerdem gibt es auch Varianten ganz ohne grafische Oberfläche.
Ich habe die Variante mit KDE Plasma getestet.
Was ich direkt richtig gelungen fand,
wenn man hier unten auf Akku klickt,
kann ich mit einem Klick direkt sagen,
dass das System nicht in den Ruhezustand gehen soll
und auch nicht den Bildschirm ausschalten soll.
Diese Nicht-Schlafen-Gehen-Funktion
ist bei anderen Betriebssystemen
oft deutlich schwieriger zu finden.
Was ich auch schön fand,
im gleichen Menü kann ich die Tastaturbeleuchtung
stufenlos einstellen
und endlich gibt es hier rechts in der Ecke
den Button zum Minimieren aller Fenster.
Wenn man einfach den leeren Desktop sehen will.
Es geht das nicht,
auch wenn man sich auf den Kopf stellt.
Und ja, ich habe das lange probiert.
Auch die Workarounds sind nicht so wie das hier.
Also einfach zack, in die Ecke, Klick und alles.
Das ist halt so ein typischer Fall von macOS.
Wenn Apple denkt, das ist nicht the way,
das zu machen, dann gibt es das halt nicht.
Das ist minimiert.
Und sonst ist das alles sehr normal Linuxig.
Programme und Updates kann man entweder
in der grafischen Oberfläche Discover installieren
oder halt Classic im Terminal
mit dem Fedora Paketmanager DNF.
Man muss sich allerdings darüber im Klaren sein,
wie groß die Architektur ist.
Und dafür gibt es etwas weniger Software als für x86.
Auch wenn ihr das meiste da finden solltet.
Ein paar große Sachen fehlen.
Zum Beispiel könnt ihr zur Zeit noch nicht
ohne weiteres Steam installieren.
Ziemlich schade.
Ja gut, ich gehe mal davon aus,
selbst wenn man Steam installieren könnte,
gibt es wahrscheinlich
die wenigsten Games dort
in einem Linux-Armbild
beziehungsweise in einem Windows-Armbild,
was dann mit Proton und so
und ich glaube,
spielen kannst du damit auch komplett knicken.
Das Videoschnittprogramm Davinci Resolve
läuft noch nicht.
Grafik-Hardware-Beschleunigung gibt es aber,
denn die Asahi-Entwicklerin
Alyssa Rosenzweig
zusammen mit Asahi Lina
die App Grafik-Treiber
reverse-engineert und nun bietet
Asahi Linux sogar standardkonforme
OpenGL ES 3.1 Treiber,
was macOS nicht hat.
Die Frage ist,
wie sieht das mit Video-Decoder
und sowas aus?
Habe ich dann, wenn ich ein 4K-Video
auf YouTube abspiele
im Browser,
habe ich da 90% CPU-Last?
Oder
geht das über die
Hardware-Decoder?
Nice, testen konnte ich das noch nicht.
SuperTux!
Ne, das ist nicht SuperTux,
das ist Tux Racer oder wie das heißt.
Was sagen das? Tux Racer?
Und 4K-YouTube-Videos auch.
Und obwohl man ja immer sagt,
dass Apple-Rechner nur wegen der engen Verzahnung
von Hard- und Software so gut laufen,
ist das ohne Apples Hilfe entstandene Fedora
doch erstaunlich leistungsfähig.
Hier, das sind die Messergebnisse
des CPU-Benchmarks.
Das wundert mich nicht,
dass die ähnlich, dass die vergleichbar sind.
Benchmarks von Geekbench 6 unter macOS
und unter Asahi Linux.
Im Single-Core erreicht Asahi 95%
der Leistung und im Multi-Core
noch 88% der Leistung.
Das ist schon ziemlich gut.
Vor allem, wenn man sich mal
andere ARM-Consumer-Geräte anschaut.
Hier zum Beispiel, das ist das Geekbench-Ergebnis
des Lenovo ThinkPad X13s.
Eines der ganz wenigen
Windows-ARM-Geräte.
Wer so ein Ding kauft, der hat auch
nicht mal alle Tassen im Schrank.
Inzwischen auch Linux, aber bei weitem
nicht so gut wie Asahi auf Macs.
Ich habe ARM-Viren ausprobiert auf dem X13s
und ja, das ist noch nichts für den Alltag.
Aber auch wenn Asahi meiner Meinung nach
echt schon geeignet ist für den Produktiv-Einsatz,
hat es gegenüber macOS doch noch
etliche Nachteile.
Das eingebaute Mikrofon funktioniert hier zum Beispiel
bei keinem Mac, USB-C-Displays
auch nicht, Thunderbolt nicht
und auch der Fingerabdruck-Laser nicht.
Der aber wohl größte Wermutstropfen ist
die deutlich kürzere Akkulaufzeit.
Ich habe auf meinem MacBook Air mit M2
mit halber Bildschirmhelligkeit im Vollbild
ein 4K-YouTube-Video abgespielt.
Einmal auf macOS und einmal auf Asahi
und der Gerechtigkeit wegen auf
beiden Systemen in Firefox.
Ja, bei macOS waren das 12 Stunden
und 30 Minuten, bei Asahi
leider nicht mal 5 Stunden.
Das spricht dafür, dass es nicht über den
Hardware-Videodecoder geht, oder?
Andersherum kann man
das ja schlecht erklären.
Das ist rein CPU-technisch
das eine und das andere geht halt über den
H.264-Decoder.
Und auch zugeklappt, also im
Standby, da hält macOS ja extrem
lange durch, also Wochen.
Schönen Gruß an Windows-Notebooks
an dieser Stelle.
Was witzig war,
auf unserem
Teambuilding-Workshop hatte
einer ein MacBook im Rucksack stecken
und das ist überhitzt und hat sich immer wieder neu
gestartet. Und da gibt es doch diesen
Sound, wenn MacBooks
starten, was sich ein bisschen
anhört wie so ein Schiffshorn.
Ich kann das nicht anders beschreiben.
Kennt ihr diesen macOS-Start-Song?
Und das hat
dann im Takt von 15
Minuten hat es dann so eine
oder am Anfang
alle 15 Minuten, dann alle 5 Minuten,
alle Minute und so, hat das Ding dann so eine
Reboot-Meldung aus seinem Rucksack gegeben.
Der Rucksack stand irgendwo in der Ecke und hat dann
laufen gemacht
aus dem Rucksack
raus, bis er dann irgendwann das Notebook
geschnappt hat, mal raus ist und versucht hat, dass es irgendwie
abkühlt.
So oft habe ich auch nur den Start-Sound gehört.
Keine Wochen, sondern Tage.
Aber auch wenn ich nicht sagen kann, ob macOS
irgendwann eingeholt wird von
Asahi, da wird sich auf jeden Fall noch
was tun. Alleine die Fortschritte
zwischen der ersten Alpha und der ersten
Alien-Version, Tag und Nacht.
Ja, und bevor ich jetzt erkläre, wie die
Installation funktioniert, wollte ich ja noch
sagen, warum man überhaupt Asahi
installieren sollte. Ja, Grund 1, weil es
cool ist, ganz einfach. Grund 2,
besseres Fenstermanagement
als bei macOS. Und das sagt nicht nur
ich. Grund 3, weil es ein guter
Skill ist, Linux zu beherrschen,
läuft das so gut wie auf allen Servern
dieser Welt. Das stimmt. Das kann man dann auf seinem
Notebook schon ein bisschen üben. Grund 4,
weil, wenn man sehr misstrauisch
Das sage ich ja auch immer, wenn es darum geht. Ah, Max, wir
lernen hier am besten Linux. Installiert euch
das, am besten in der VM neben
eurem bestehenden Betriebssystem und
versucht das mal für tägliche Aufgaben zu
benutzen.
Und dementsprechend gibt es dann bestimmte Sachen, die stören euch,
die müsst ihr umkonfigurieren. Aber mit der
Zeit gewöhnt man sich dran und man lernt auf dem
Weg enorm viel. Gerade was
Kommandozeilen-Tools, Bedienung
angeht, welche Config-Dateien
und wie das Ganze so läuft.
Durch tägliches Linux benutzen
lernt man fast mehr, wie durch
reine Linux-Tutorials.
...durch die Welt geht
und einem Open-Source-Betriebssystem
mehr vertraut als einem geschlossenen.
Grund 5, okay, das ist super
speziell, aber das gilt auf jeden Fall
für mich, weil ich halt viel mit Raspis
herum hantiere und dafür gerne auf meinem
Arbeitsrechner ein Betriebssystem hätte, mit dem ich
das von Raspis genutzte Ext4-Datei-System
lesen und schreiben kann.
Geht das nicht mit MacOS? So, jetzt geht's ans Eingemachte.
Erstmal eine Warnung, es ist zwar
sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass ihr euren Mac
komplett kaputt macht mit der ASEI-Installation,
aber man hat ja auch schon scharfe
Pusten gesehen. Macht wirklich
ein Backup vorher 15 Ausrufezeichen.
Und was noch wichtig ist, die Installation
ist recht einfach und die zeige ich euch
auch hier im Detail, aber für die
Deinstallation müsst ihr in der Lage sein,
einen englischsprachigen Artikel im
ASEI-Linux-Wiki nachzuvollziehen.
Guckt euch das am besten vorher an, ob ihr
da Zeit und Lust zu habt. Es gibt
ein Uninstall-Skript, das mit
einem Befehl alles weglöscht,
aber ihr müsst zumindest danach die MacOS-Partition
manuell im Terminal wieder vergrößern.
Also schaut da vorher mal
drüber, ob ihr euch das zutraut.
So, nun aber los mit dem Fun.
Ihr installiert ASEI, indem ihr in MacOS
einfach ein Terminal öffnet und da
dann das eingebt. Ist das
cool, oder? Also ich find's im Vergleich
Ja, wir
keulen uns ein Skript
aus dem Internet und pipen es nach ASEI.
Beste Idee.
Ich will ASEI darüber nicht so sehr flamen, ich mach
das auch laufen.
... zu irgendwelcher USB-Stick-Hantiererei.
Sehr, sehr elegant. Also Befehl
eintippen, los geht's. Da tippt ihr
jetzt euer Administrator-Passwort ein
und merkt euch euren Username,
der da... Man kann nur hoffen, dass
niemand Zugriff auf diese Sache bekommt
und das Skript mal austauscht durch irgendwas
anderes. Ganz oben vor eurem
Prompt steht. Zumal man ja auch noch direkt
im Anschluss root werden muss. Ja, und
dann geht's hiermit weiter. Ihr drückt R
für Resize, also Größe der aktuellen
Partition ändern und jetzt müsst ihr euch
etwas konzentrieren, weil verwirrend.
Ihr werdet jetzt gefragt, wie groß eure
MacOS-Partition am Ende sein soll.
Nicht die ASEI-Partition. Könnt ihr
zum Beispiel eine Prozentangabe eingeben
oder zum Beispiel 300 GB. Wenn ihr
eine 500 GB SSD habt,
bekommt ASEI dann 200 GB
zugewiesen. Also 500 minus
300 gleich 200. Minimal
solltet ihr ungefähr 60 GB
freimachen für ASEI.
Es könnte sein, dass das Skript jetzt wegen irgendwelchen
Time-Machine-Snapshots rummeckert.
Diese Snapshots oder auch nicht abgeschlossene
MacOS-Updates können eigentlich
vorhandenen Speicherplatz belegen.
Also ihr hättet beispielsweise eigentlich 300 GB
freien Speicher, aber wegen der Snapshots
praktisch nur noch 200 GB.
Wenn euch das trotzdem reicht, dann könnt ihr
mit der Installation einfach weitermachen.
Man denkt immer daran, ihr müsst eingehen, wie groß
die MacOS-Partition am Ende sein soll.
Nicht die ASEI-Partition, wie gesagt.
Lest genau, was da steht. Ich weiß,
das ist etwas verwirrend. Wenn ihr diese
Meldung bekommt mit den Time-Machine-Snapshots
und ihr den Speicherplatz freigeben wollt,
brecht ihr das Skript jetzt ab. Also einfach
das Terminal-Fenster schließen und dann könnt ihr
die Snapshots löschen. Das Skript
verweist euch auf einen Artikel, in dem steht,
wie das geht. Den habe ich euch auch in
der Beschreibung verlinkt. So, weiter geht's.
Wenn das Skript fertig ist mit
Partitionieren, seht ihr das hier.
Die Videos sind immer angenehm geschnitten,
muss ich sagen.
... gibt es 325 GB freien Platz.
Dann einfach F tippen, also ASEI
auf die neue freie Partition
installieren und jetzt könnt ihr auswählen,
welche Geschmacksrichtung ihr wollt. 1
ist die Standard-Variante mit KDE-Plasma
Benutzeroberfläche, 2 ist
mit GNOME. Ist Geschmackssache.
So, und dann könnt ihr entscheiden, ob ihr die komplette
freie Partition nutzen wollt oder nur...
Jetzt wird die i3-Enjoyer dabei.
... ein Teil. Wenn es die komplette sein soll...
... gibt's inzwischen eine vernünftige Lösung
für Virtualisierung auf M1. Keine Ahnung.
... gibt hier Macs ein. Ich hab kein Mac.
Bei unserer Installation hier wollen wir
nur 80 GB verwenden, also gibt man
hier 80 GB ein.
Jetzt noch einen Namen für das Betriebssystem vergeben
und los geht die.
... sollte man Linux problemlos
zum Laufen bekommen. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie gut
Virtualisierung... Passt ja zur letzten
Frage, wie gut Virtualisierung
auf ARM, Mac...
... funktioniert. Auf alten
Macs auf jeden Fall. Easy.
Installation. Wie das
jetzt ist, keine Ahnung. Dann kann man das macOS-Admin-Passwort
eingeben und jetzt kann man entscheiden,
ob man den ASI-Entwicklern ein paar Infos
über die eigene Installation schickt.
Nein. Kann man ruhig machen, da sind keine persönlichen
Daten drin, aber muss man natürlich
auch nicht. So, jetzt nochmal konzentrieren.
System ist installiert. Wenn ihr jetzt
Enter drückt, fährt der Rechner runter und
schaltet sich aus. So lange warten, bis er
wirklich aus ist. Und jetzt, ganz wichtig...
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie gut das Zeug... Mein Parallel-
ist ja VMware.
Moment, war Parallels VMware?
Ne, Fusion ist VMware. Fusion ist
VMware. VMware Fusion.
... den Einschaltknopf drücken
und gedrückt halten, bis da steht
Loading Startup Options.
Wenn man dann die Boot-Eigene sieht, Fedora...
Das ist sehr schick gemacht.
... auswählen. Jetzt sieht man einen macOS
Wiederherstellungsdialog. Da wählt man dann den
Admin-User aus, gibt das Passwort
ein und fortfahren. So.
Jetzt öffnet sich ein Terminal-Fenster.
Hier dann nochmal den Benutzernamen. Hattet ihr euch ja
am Anfang gemerkt. Eingeben und das Passwort.
Dann kommt nochmal eine Sicherheitsabfrage, die ihr
mit Y wie Yes bestätigt. Dann
nochmal Benutzername und Passwort eingeben.
Wir hatten das übrigens auf einem unserer Testrechner,
dass wir nach einem Reboot diesen
Wiederherstellungsdialog plus Login und
Passwort ein zweites Mal durchgehen mussten.
Also, das ist nicht schlimm. Danach sollte dann alles
gehen. Ja, Rechner fährt sich runter und
jetzt bootet Asahi. Willkommen!
Wenn ihr übrigens nicht Asahi als
Standard-Boot-System haben wollt, könnt ihr übers
Boot-Menü, Einschaltknopf lange drücken, ne,
kennt ihr schon, wieder in macOS reinbooten,
und dort in den eigentlich nicht schlecht
gemacht. Stellung dann unter Start-Volume
das Standard-OS auswählen,
was ihr haben wollt. Das ist
in der Tat deutlich einfacher,
als das unter Windows ist.
Gut, unter Windows geht das
gar nicht, ja. Du brauchst dann halt
einen Boot-Manager, der Linux booten kann
und Windows booten kann.
Das ist eigentlich ganz gut gemacht.
Mein Fazit. Also, ich werde
Asahi auf jeden Fall auf meinem
MacBook lassen. Einfach, weil ich's cool
finde, auf meinem Mac Linux zu
benutzen zu können. Fühlt sich auch irgendwie
so rebellisch an. Ich hab Locking Glass
noch nicht getestet, weil ich keinen
GPU-Path-Thru mache.
Was ich da drüber gelesen hab,
so mit quasi RAM kopieren
und quasi auf dem
Host-Betriebssystem dann die
Grafik-Ausgabe trotz GPU-Path-Thru darstellen,
klang sehr nice. Gemacht hab ich's
selbst noch nie. Und ich bin echt gespannt,
wie sich das weiterentwickelt, vor allem was die
Akkulaufzeit angeht und ob womöglich
irgendwann Steam mit Proton funktioniert.
Denn dann könnte es sein, dass deutlich
mehr Spiele unter Mac-Linux laufen
als unter Steam auf macOS.
Aber in der Hinsicht... Aber allein schon, weil's
arme Architektur ist, ich kann's mir nicht vorstellen.
...wäre schon ganz schön komplexes Unterfangen.
Da bräuchte man dann nämlich nicht nur die
Windows-zu-Linux-Kompatibilitätsschicht,
sondern gleich auch noch die von
x86 zu 8. Ja, genau.
Auf jeden Fall ist Asahi ein beeindruckendes
Projekt und wenn ihr da mitmachen wollt,
hier ist eine Liste mit offenen Sachen
auf der Asahi-To-Do-Liste.
Apropos offene Sachen, falls euch noch interessiert,
wie das mit meinem neulich im Livestream
passiert.
Ja, ich will mitmachen. Ich bezweifle, dass ich
den Skill habe mitzumachen.
Nee, ich würde auch nicht mitmachen wollen.
Ah!
Fractal Design Enjoyer!
Dem nehme ich das auch gerade auf.
Und die Grafikkarte ist jetzt auch richtig verschraubt.
Also das hat drei Kollegen erfordert,
bis wir das dann endlich mal hatten.
Danke Shahin an dieser Stelle.
Und so sieht das Ding jetzt aus von innen.
Warum ist die Grafikkarte hochkant?
Oder habe ich das...
sehe ich das falsch?
Nee.
Hier ist oben, oder?
Hier ist oben.
Hier ist der...
Hier ist unten. Hier ist unten vom Netzteil.
Hier ist oben.
Jetzt. Ich habe es nicht...
Ich wurde verwirrt von der Mainboard-Schrift hier.
Hier ist oben.
Ich bin echt zufrieden damit.
Auch wenn das Ding im Leerlauf
90 Watt wegballert.
Wir machen dazu auf jeden Fall noch ein Video.
Aber das wird noch ein paar Wochen dauern.
Tschüss.
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk
Jeden Tag Leeko fletschen.
Wisst ihr, was ich mir noch angucken wollte?
Das hier.
Das habe ich schon vor ein paar Tagen gesehen,
das Video.
Und zwar, es hat irgendjemand anscheinend
eine...
Flashkarte
für die Switch
rausgehauen.
Wo man selbstverständlich
nur selbst gedumpte ROMs drauf macht.
Obviously.
Und ich wollte mal das Video dazu machen. Ob das das ist,
was ich denke.
Also ich erkläre euch mal kurz,
wie das beim Nintendo DS gelaufen ist.
Beim Nintendo DS gab es Flashkarten.
Da konntest du in die Karte selbst
eine Micro SD Karte reinschieben, so wie hier.
Und da konntest du quasi
dem Nintendo DS
Du hattest dann sogar die Möglichkeit
in ein Custom Menü zu gehen.
Du konntest dann quasi Spiele von der Micro SD Karte
starten im Endeffekt.
So ging das beim Nintendo DS.
Und das war super komfortabel,
weil du auf einer Micro SD Karte
irgendwie einfach mal 60 Games mitnehmen konntest.
Aber nur selbst gedumpte ROMs
logischerweise.
Und ich will jetzt wissen,
ob das das ist für die Switch,
wie es beim DS war.
...modification of the console.
Simply plug and play.
Now, this device
is essentially a Switch cartridge
with an SD card slot
that contains your Switch ROMs.
The format itself is said to be different
from the standard XCI
and NSP formats that you've probably
been used to if you use emulators
or you've seen floating around the Internet.
Now, the Mixed Switch consists of two products.
The Switch Card itself,
that has the Micro SD card slot
and the Mixed Switch Dumper,
which allows you to take backups
of your legally owned Nintendo Switch games.
Siehste, man kann damit natürlich
nur selbst gedumpte ROMs spielen.
An den ihrer Stelle würde ich das
auch genau so auf der Webseite schreiben.
Und was man sonst noch
damit machen kann,
der Fantasie der Leute überlassen,
weil sonst ist dann Nintendo
schneller am Start.
Als sie gucken können.
Now, while the legalities of this product
is not really something that I want to talk about
in this episode, I do want to stress
that this is a device that people have
wanted pretty much since the very first
day of the Nintendo Switch's life cycle.
Ja, ach!
Now, of course, a device like this is very interesting
as it has shades of the R4
or Sky 3DS cards for the Nintendo 3DS.
Ja.
Okay, für ein 3DS hatte ich so eine Karte nicht.
Ich hatte für den normalen Nintendo DS
hatte ich eine Cyclo-Cycle.
Cyclo-DS hieß das Ding, glaube ich.
Es war auch so eine Flash-Karte.
Obviously!
Was anderes würde ich auch nicht machen.
Käme mir nicht in den Sinn.
Es ist wichtig,
dass ich Backups machen kann
von meinen Spielen.
Deswegen brauche ich das.
Was ich noch dazu sagen möchte,
wurde im August 2023 erstellt.
Etwas über die ganze Sache machte mich denken,
dass Notorious Group Team Executor
vielleicht der Gruppe hinter all dem ist.
Und ich sage das,
weil dank einer recenten Erkenntnis
von der Gemeinschaft,
es scheint, als ob diese AfterTimeX Twitter-Account
und Website
mit der MIG-Switch-Flash-Karte
verabschiedet ist.
Das Team, das hinter der Flash-Karte ist.
Ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht?
Eigentlich ist mir fast egal,
wer das herstellt.
Aber die Leute,
die in den letzten Jahren
nach den Anrufen gemacht wurden,
haben vielleicht wieder herausgefunden,
dass sie das Produkt
am Ende ihres Lebens eröffnen.
Also da sieht man schon,
in welcher Legalitätszone sich die Leute
da meistens bewegen,
wenn die untertauchen müssen,
weil sie sonst in den Knast kommen.
Jetzt, bevor wir anfangen,
möchte ich sagen,
dass viel dieser Information
da draußen ist und verfügbar ist.
Es gibt eine Geschichte
über den Modchip und die Konsolenszenen
seit Jahren.
Die MIG-Switch-Flash-Karte ist noch nicht
veröffentlicht.
Wir haben eine Website, ein Video
und eine Twitter-Account, die das Produkt
veröffentlichen.
Wir wissen nicht, was das Gerät ist,
bis wir es in der Hand bekommen.
Was interessant ist, ist genau so,
wie Nintendo reagiert.
Und man kann vermuten,
dass sie reagieren werden.
Ich glaube, es wird ein Switch-Gerät sein,
aber wir haben das Gerät noch nicht.
Die Frage ist,
was die ausnutzen,
ob das was ist,
was Nintendo so einfach fixen kann
mit einem Firmware-Update.
Weil wenn das Ding
nach einer legit Cartridge aussieht,
Nintendo muss ja immerhin
auch sicherstellen,
dass alle offiziell verkauften Spiele
weiter funktionieren.
Eventuell kann da Nintendo
auch gar nichts dagegen machen.
Gegen die Funktionen
von dem Ding.
Die können sicherlich gegen den Hersteller vorgehen.
Wobei es halt auch,
je nachdem, wie das Ding hergestellt ist,
das ist rechtlich ja immer nicht so einfach,
an sich nicht grundsätzlich verboten ist,
so ein Gerät zu bauen.
Das ist aber immer
alles sehr schwierig,
das einzuschätzen.
Ich bin ja auch kein Anwalt.
Also, mal gespannt.
Aber zumindest, dass der Typ
untergetaucht ist,
weil er sonst in den Knast gekommen wäre,
spricht ja wohl schon ein bisschen dafür,
dass da noch andere Sachen gelaufen sind.
Das ist natürlich für den
sehr praktisch gewesen,
dass das geleakt wurde.
Ich will hier nicht zu technisch werden,
weil ich nicht ein Hardware-Expert bin.
Und zweitens ist es
nicht wirklich so wichtig.
Was hier aber wichtig ist,
ist, dass der Lotus 3 Chip
im Jahr 2021 entdeckt wurde.
Dieser Prozess würde dann helfen,
die geheimen Hardware-Keys für Kommunikation zu erhalten
und die Game-Card-Zertifikate zu entdecken.
Ich sollte hier kurz stoppen
und bemerken, dass jeder physische
Switch-Game-Cartridge
sein eigenes Zertifikat enthält.
Wenn ich jetzt spekuliere,
würde der Lotus 3 Chip
einen FPGA-Cartridge haben,
genau wie der R4 Gold
auf dem 3DS,
und er reproduziert den Game-Cartridge-Chip,
welcher in der Cartridge gebaut ist.
Und er wird effektiv
die physische
Switch-Cartridge-Funktion emulieren.
Jedes Nintendo Switch-Cartridge
ist einzigartig entdeckt,
wie wir schon gesagt haben.
Und das ist um Games zu tracken.
Also zum Beispiel,
wenn man ein physisches Switch-Game kauft
auf einem anderen Gerät.
Also das TLDR hier ist,
dass es nur einmal einen Game-Card
mit einem gewissen Seriennummer
oder Zertifikat geben sollte.
Also wenn ein Szenario passiert,
in dem zwei der gleichen Spiele
mit den gleichen Seriennummern online gesehen
und von Nintendo entdeckt werden,
kann der Game-Card-Seriennummer
dann blockiert werden,
um das physische Spiel unverwendbar zu machen
und die Konsole selbst könnte gebannt werden.
Also wenn du ein Mixed Switch-Game
mit deinem eigenen Gerät
backst,
wenn du nicht deine Spiele verkaufst.
Aber wenn Nintendo zwei der gleichen Spiele
mit dem gleichen Seriennummern entdeckt,
dann wird Nintendo sicherlich einsteigen.
Nach dem AfterTimeX-Twitter-Post
sagten sie, nach dem Review des Websites,
es scheint, dass die Backup-Roms,
die auf der Internetseite
fliegen, nicht unterstützt werden.
Sie sprechen natürlich von dem XCI-Format.
Denn der Format, den der Mixed Switch
benutzt, ist etwas anders.
Wir verstehen nicht alle technischen...
Ich finde es immer sehr interessant,
wie die dahinter kommen.
Ich fand ja auch die Story super spannend,
wie sie damals die Wii geknackt haben.
Eines der ersten Spiele,
die dazu beigetragen haben,
mit einem Bug,
dass man die Wii hacken kann,
war ja Twilight Princess.
Da musstest du in Twilight...
Der Reißverschluss reibt die ganze Zeit
am Headset-Kabel
und macht komische Geräusche.
Bei der Wii war das ja so,
in Twilight Princess
musstest du einen manipulierten
Spielstand laden,
von der SD-Karte.
In dem manipulierten Spielstand
war der Name vom Pferd
manipuliert.
Und dann musstest du
das Spiel starten
von der SD-Karte
mit dem manipulierten Pferdenamen
im Spielstand rückwärts laufen
und mit einem NPC reden.
Und der NPC hat den Namen
vom Pferd ausgesprochen.
Und in dem Moment,
wo der Name vom Pferd ausgesprochen wurde,
der zu lang war,
ist das Game zufällig
auf irgendeinen Speicherbereich gejumpt,
der im USB-Adressraum lief.
Und so konntest du dann
von USB Sachen nachladen.
War ganz weird damals,
wie sie die Sachen
auf der Wii geknackt haben.
Ich hab da bestimmt ein paar Sachen
weggelassen,
von diesem Twilight Princess Hack war so.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Irgendein Overflow,
weil der Pferdename zu lang war
und da ist dann glücklicherweise
durch den manipulierten Pferdenamen
genau im USB-Adressbereich rausgekommen.
Deswegen war es ja auch lange Zeit so,
dass du für Customsachen auf der Wii
nur den linken anstatt den rechten
USB-Slot verwenden konntest.
Also das hat jetzt nichts mit dem
Speicherbereich an sich zu tun,
aber das war nur auf den linken USB-Slot beschränkt.
Und zwar bei Windows.
Aber man kann sicher sein,
dass die Releases zu sehen sind,
nicht zu lange dauert,
um kompatible Repacks zur Piracy Masses
zu machen,
da die Instruktionen, die auf dem Website
veröffentlicht werden, klar sind.
Also es scheint ein einfaches Prozess zu sein.
Das contradicts Informationen,
die Michael Sires vorgesehen hat,
die beurteilt hat, dass Nintendo
Game Cart Certificates beurteilt wurde
so weit zurück als 2018.
Und es ist verstanden,
Guck mal, habt ihr es gesehen?
Die Kekomrads sind wieder am Start hier.
Die hackende Kekomrads.
Wie ist Gary Bowser in all dem involviert?
Wenn die Ausstellung des AftertimeX Twitter-Accounts
keine roten Flaggen ausgesetzt hat,
ist es seitdem entdeckt, dass die DNS-Rekorde,
die von dem AftertimeX.com-Website zurückgezogen wurden,
bis rund um September 3, 2023 inaktiv geblieben ist,
als das Domain mail.garyopa.com ausgeschlossen wurde.
Für diejenigen, die die Geschichte des Team Executor erinnern,
habe ich ein Video darüber gemacht,
in 2021, wo drei Männer...
Letztendlich ist es auch fast egal,
wer da dahinter steckt.
Gary hat selbst versucht,
in der Zeit, in der er in die Kekomrads kam,
sich von der Entdeckung entfernt zu lassen
und beurteilt hat, dass es nichts mehr war
als eine DNS-Rekorde, die...
Ja, klar.
Er wurde erwischt.
Nein, nein, nein.
Aber er hat es nicht entdeckt,
was ich glaube, ziemlich bemerkenswert ist.
Gary Bowser war Admin für verschiedene Websites
über die Jahre,
wie Xbox Scene, MaxConsole.com
und mehr letztlich GBA Temp,
die SXOS-Produkte promotiert,
um nur ein paar zu nennen.
Es ist also keine wirkliche Überraschung,
dass sein Name wieder einmal hinter all dem ist.
Wenn ihr jetzt zurückgeht und meine Geschichte
von Team Executor aus 2020 schaut,
Aber die scheinen es schon drauf zu haben.
Irgendwelche 0815-Random-Dudes
entwickeln sowas halt auch nicht.
Ja, das ist nicht okay.
Okay.
Er ist ein integraler Teil des Produkts.
Ohne ihn gibt es kein Website,
kein Twitter und kein Advertisement.
Ohne ihn gibt es kein Advertisement.
Nun, um seinen Namen in all dem zu sehen,
Der Chinese hatte auch Glück.
Der musste nicht ins Knast für sowas.
Der hat bestimmt noch voll gefeiert.
Nothing has been learnt here.
Gary set up a GoFundMe-Page
to kind of rebuild his life
after he got out of prison.
And I was someone that was happy to help.
I donated money to the cause
and I wished him well.
I really, you know, felt like he got
a really rough deal by Nintendo.
But if I was Gary Bowser right now,
I would be taken ab.
I would be taking this opportunity
to say to myself,
get the fuck out of this situation
while you can.
This is a warning.
This specific thing that's come up,
this DNS record that has been exposed.
Right now, there is nothing illegal.
There is nothing wrong with what's happening.
But I would take this opportunity
just to get out.
Wie dem auch sei.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was da passiert.
Weil so eine Flashkarte
für die Switch,
wenn die so,
so ähnlich funktioniert wie beim DS,
wäre schon, wäre schon mega nice.
Natürlich nur für Backups, obviously.
Das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht.
Also, wenn er Pech hat,
muss er jetzt direkt wieder in den Knast.
Wie viele Tabs willst du noch offen haben?
Naja, da ein paar, da ein paar, da ein paar.
Und ich habe zur Abwechslung,
oh, hier habe ich nur einen Tab auf.
Was ist denn hier los, Leute?
Ah ja, ich habe gerade rebooted, deswegen.
Ich meine, ich muss irgendwie
meinen RAM auslassen.
Guck mal, ich habe, ich habe,
ich habe nur 25 Gig von 67 Gig aus,
von 68 Gig ausgeladen.
68 Gig?
What?
Achtundsech...
Ah, 64, da oben steht es.
Da oben steht es 64.
Okay, was ist das für ein Knopf da oben?
Wo kommt dieses N her?
Chat, wer, wer, wer, wer von euch,
wer von euch ist es?
Von Nintendo.
Das ist irgendwie aus dem Chat.
Was ist das?
Windows Zeug, Mann.
Wer ist es wieder?
Guck mal, da ist es wieder.
Das folgt mir.
Jetzt ist es weg.
Ja, ich muss doch meinen RAM irgendwie voll kriegen.
Guck mal, und wir haben
auch ein geiler Graph, oder?
Auch ein geiler Graph.
Ach, hier oben steht was.
Null, aber man kann ja nicht anklicken,
dass man wirklich sieht, wie viel sich,
ich meine, 0 bis 64.
Und was ist das hier jetzt?
So eine Skala nebendran oder irgendwas zum,
zum Hovern, dass man sieht, was es ist.
Wäre schon ganz sinnig, oder?
Ah, das ist nicht, nicht im Scope gewesen beim Task Manager.
Warum ist da ein Chrome-Icon so blau?
Weil das nicht Chrome, sondern Chromium ist.
Chrome habe ich auch.
Guck, das ist der normale Chrome.
Das ist quasi Chrome mit ein paar Google Sachen removed.
Und das ist der Original Chrome.
Also ich benutze im Prinzip drei verschiedene Browser.
Ich benutze Firefox, Firefox, Chrome und Chromium.
Unter Linux verwende ich eigentlich nur Chromium und Firefox.
Und warum sollte ich da noch extra Chrome installieren?
Ja, macht ja keinen Sinn.
Leute, ich habe übertrieben Hunger.
Es gibt nachher, wenn ich fertig essen bin,
gibt es ein neues Video auf YouTube.
Habe ich gestern schon hochgeladen.
Im Stream hattest du schon mal Rust Rover ausprobiert.
Ja, habe ich.
Hat mich jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig überzeugt.
Ich habe aber auch keinen Vergleich dazu, wie beispielsweise
Visual Studio Code oder so mit, oder Wim mit Rust ist.
Gibt es Nudeln mit Lachs? Nein.
Nein, es gibt heute kein Nudeln mit Lachs.
Ich habe es euch gestern erzählt, was es gibt.
Wer aufgepasst hat, weiß es noch.
Es gibt heute Lachs mit...
Nein, nicht.
Mit Reis, korrekt.
Potato Bauer...
Lachs mit Kokain.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so gut zusammenpasst, aber Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof und so, hast du ja alles verfügbar.
Reis mit Lachs gibt es, korrekt.
Wann nächster Stream? Wann nächster Stream?
Ich hoffe mal heute Abend.
Aber ihr wisst, wie das ist.
Ich nehme mir da immer viel vor und kriege das meiste nicht hin.
Gutluck, have fun.
Wie sieht das eigentlich mit der Cannabis-Legalisierung so aus?
Habt ihr da was mitbekommen?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt direkt Vape Nation starten will, sondern ich kann mich nur daran erinnern, dass sie das groß angekündigt haben, bis jetzt nichts passiert ist.
Soon.
Verstehe.
Was ich für mich deutlich relevanter empfinde, ist, dass es...
Was mit dem Deutschland-Ticket jetzt passiert.
Ich hoffe ja, sie verkacken es nicht.
Und nicht ausprobiert.
Ich geh jetzt was essen, Leute. Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Wir sehen uns eventuell heute Abend.
Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.